[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
welcome everybody to the 20 billion
dollar Studio
I just want to put this out there that
we I may have some top secret
documents don't tell me my safe
and you're never going to get them
yeah just the Department of Justice they
may be um what's the ones he sold
they're not just top secret they're like
oh yeah
SCI top secret special access yeah guess
what we're working with we're working
with Christopher Ray terrorists
folks
we're working with Christopher Ray well
technically not Christopher Ray Donald
Trump's appointee but a body double of
Christopher Ray he smells like silver
and uh he retrieved the documents that
he gave us he gave it directly to us he
said uh Donald Trump can't have these uh
you are the one who is rightfully
allowed to have these documents because
we're liberals they were they were
Declassified uh by uh
when they were handed to us yeah well
we've got a great show here Hassan how
are you doing you well what were you
doing you're filming all I've been I've
been going crazy we we rebranded uh we
revamped the podcast fear and maulding
the fear and me and will yeah and it's
not political at all
um interesting okay well and and as you
know I had Jeff on the last episode
actually yeah well Jeff has really good
takes on the Russian Ukraine conflict
well we don't like I said we don't do
politics I'm just kidding but that is
really interesting for you actually I
like that it doesn't overlap with our
podcast now no and it doesn't overlap
with uh it doesn't overlap with like uh
my my commentary in general yeah just
like saying like finally you know I I
you know I love your takes but I don't
want to [ __ ] hear it yeah three times
over you know what I mean love that love
that fear and I still feel like it's
missing something yeah just it's missing
the second part I like it I have a weird
thing about I think we talked about this
no like I have a weird thing about like
naming conventions I feel like if it's
weird but then the podcast like but then
the brand pops off then all of a sudden
you have ownership of that and everyone
will think about it
um but yeah but what the [ __ ] can I get
a ninja G fuel this is the last one he
flexing on me like this yo you took our
last episode well you guys don't have
any uh cold brew anymore in the fridge
so I'm just I'm just desperate for
energy that's actually a problem yeah
come on guys that's a problem
you took my last chug jug bro I am a
little worried about that I feel like
this is gonna make me I'm gonna chug
this and then rush to the bathroom but
it'll be all right yeah you'll be fine
gift well uh yeah I've been doing I've
been doing friends podcasts and stuff
just going around when are you coming on
fear and that's the real question that's
what people are asking don't worry I'm
coming on fear and uh don't worry the
chairs are are not very ergonomic but
like you will you have to sit proper
like this so there will be no side
profile photos
as long as you can promise there's no
side profile I will do your podcast okay
no compromising photos only
because I'm I'm like that like I'm the
same way I don't like you look good from
every angle that's not true but thank
you I'd like to see the angle you look
bad at what's the angle you look bad at
I don't know I feel like I mean I got a
little bit I got a little bit shut up
shut the [ __ ] you know what I mean if I
sit down I feel like I'm worried that my
like belly like I might have a little
belly that's the side profile to get you
as well probably yeah I see
well anyway listen we've got a lot of
new stuff to talk about um of course
Stephen Crowder was banned which we all
love that we celebrate that yeah
probably temporary I don't know how he
gets so many bands to be honest like
that man is suspended what feels like
every week if he's not doing some like
racist caricature he interviewed some
psycho uh the governor for uh Arizona
candidate this this lady is all for
[ __ ] rocker uh and I guess that got
her him a
a suspension so [ __ ] stupid which I
love I mean yeah and there's that to
talk about we also have coming up I want
to slam on Dr Oz who is actually just
this tiniest [ __ ] ever I mean what is
with this guy let's go I I love I love
[ __ ] on Dr Oz I I made fun of him
last night in Turkish
right he's Turkish he is Turkish yeah my
I think my grandfather knows his dad oh
[ __ ] you he they better have one like
they might be from like the same Village
or some [ __ ] they tell him to stop the
game was not gonna listen it's just Dr
Oz is a demon on his own you know he
just
he's doing all the worst [ __ ] yeah I
mean he made his career Shilling uh fake
medical product he's also bringing great
dishonor to Turkey which is really this
is the worst thing you can do honestly
right and that and what's the punishment
for dishonor to Turkey
they just say that you're Greek I was
hoping you that's it people people
forever will be like oh no he's Greek
Union he's Greek bro he's Greek
yeah I was thinking oh God I can't even
make jokes about death anymore it sucks
but I was gonna say the you know the the
the the punishment for dishonoring
turkey is the d word
um death yeah thank you Wendy
not a callback you can't even say that
what God damn you think you're gonna
can't I'm just I'm on the road I'm
coming again I'm coming on the road man
I can't be wishing death on people
anymore I'm not wishing well yeah you
can't yeah yeah
I just still don't understand it but I'd
be like is it wishing death on some yeah
I could say I'd be happy if they died
would that be acceptable or no I'm not
talking about anyone particular no you
can't say that that's wishing death
that's wishing that pretty sure that's
wishing death on someone
my workaround is like uh I just say
usually like
through the legal process they would be
executed by a Military Tribunal if there
was Justice in the world you know what I
mean like through the proper channels
yeah like even capital punishment still
exists in America you know right right
right sure Espionage Act yeah why people
die well I think the Trump one is like
specifically just uh like five-year
sentence which used to be a one-year
sentence but then Trump made it five
years right yeah of course he was like I
hate people I hate Hillary Clinton I
hate people who steal classified
documents or misuse them or mutilate
them
uh you know no but just to clarify if I
say I would be happy if somebody died
how's that wishing death
not I'm not saying that word never ever
do it it is death okay no I I don't
think you say that I could say what if
they [ __ ] fell off a cliff on
accident
dude there are so many okay here's the
thing what if he took us visiting the
Grand Canyon and just you know a little
too close to the edge and Tumble down
and then I'll be like oh that's sad news
and I would rather die than do that so
the thing is there are so many
incredibly creative and fun ways to tell
someone to kill themselves and like the
internet does really limit your ability
to say that to people and it kind of
sucks in a way because like as someone
who gets told uh to kill himself all the
time like literally non-stop uh by
people who are supposedly my allies too
which is really strange but anyways
besides the point
um I do understand like how how fun it
is to say it like that's [ __ ] up but
it's like so fun to say but I just try
to say like if somebody incidentally
dies I'm not telling him to kill
themselves they if if somebody dies I
can you know or or when I say like I'm
like great
I don't know if you guys are getting me
I'm not effectively perish yeah just
perish bro well I just got pairs usually
well what I end up doing is I usually
I'm just like I hope you go away like
that's what I said disappear yeah just
go away
yeah actually what's interesting though
to talk we've been touching on Trump
because that story has developed a lot
since last week because last week we
were debating is the last week he got
raided and we talked is it a nothing
burger or is it a something Burger I
thought it was a nothing Burger but it
turns out it might be more of a
something burger what are your thoughts
on that
I mean
with Donald Trump the fact that it's a
like even a something Burger could
technically be a nothing Burger yo let
me get some of those yeah let me hit
this sorry guys we're just we got a
coffee delivery was this the one that
got recalled where no no let me get that
one uh no thank you it wasn't rice right
I think that [ __ ] got recalled bro it's
got 200 milligrams if it's something if
it has oat in it if it has oat in it
that probably did get recalled oh we had
a whole fridge of these and then there
was like some what the what are you
trying to kill me is he I don't think
this is it let me uh yes it has oat milk
latte bro we got recall brother you want
this I don't think it's I don't think
it's that brand I don't think it's that
brand I don't think it's not that yeah
so the one in the carton I thought it
was the same brand no no the one that
got recalled was like slumped in or some
[ __ ] like that you know what I think you
know you know what hasn't gotten
recalled and won't get recalled ninja G
fuel ninja cotton no never never hey do
you feel ninja send us some more of that
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah do you even need coffee
this is rice the one that was recalled
was Oatley okay so am I good for this
why do you think all oat milk latte's
got I thought I thought some of the
products I thought some of the products
that have oat milk in them got caught
recalled as well and potentially what am
I catching by drinking this what was the
recall botulism oh botulism yeah just a
little bit of body
a little bit about you I'm already
bought you like uh like uh Steve MRE
1987 you know that guy
you don't know about Steve MRE oh my God
it's a YouTube Legend dude what the [ __ ]
shouts out to Steve MRE 1989 sorry Steve
Emory Steve 1989 Emery info I'm not
going on your podcast oh dude what
that's not that's not that's not that's
not gonna happen nowhere you want me to
look something up Steve what now Steve
and Steven Andrew Thomas who's also
known as Steve 1989 MRE info
Andrew Thomas or just just that's not
Steve Andrew Thomas
yep there it is that's that beautiful
that's that beautiful handsome man right
there big fan of this guy uh he's famous
for eating um MREs or meals ready to eat
okay so that's what you eat in the
military when you're in uh you know when
you're at a forward operating base they
got like delicious ones okay they got
really awful ones
um he eats vintage military rashes his
financial times has adequately pointed
out in this title
um and he's famous for eating tack from
like I think like the Civil War like he
will oh yeah no no he eats like he eats
stuff from like is he trying to improve
something or he eats like super old MREs
like he's had like
I think he had like a like a Japanese
kamikaze pilot meal ready to eat like he
eats like fascinating [ __ ] what did they
feed the LA what did they get I mean I
don't even there's definitely now what
does it matter no no for real no that's
what I'm saying like he straight up uh
eats like actually old food and you do
that and I think he almost he did I
think almost get botulism if I'm not
mistaken I need to almost get botulism
or he might have gotten botulism let me
see
uh this is a yeah I heard one MRE caused
Steve to go to hospital but this is all
speculation because he doesn't reveal
that part but why does he do it why Love
of the Game babe yeah exactly just in
the love of the game I mean this is this
is what the internet is for right like
eating rotten food for the for the
[ __ ] game of it
so what I mean by that is like he is
first of all oh yeah old MREs will have
like cigarettes in them and he will
smoke the cigarette like it's so sick
where does he get this [ __ ] oh there he
is there's a man my man there's a
massive community of fans online I am
one of them I literally have his
merchandise well let me open it
let's see what the [ __ ] he's up to Steve
oh Steve 1989 has been with your mom I
mean that's just the meme I think but
here let's see
okay we can do better than that
Steve
1989. this is a wrap I wonder what he's
been up to I feel like he's he's eating
all of them he hate the the PRC MREs are
really bad notoriously bad uh according
to Steve no he's super popular yeah
these are insane views
bro I thought this was just like some
weird Niche [ __ ] you were in no dude I
mean what back in the day it was kind of
Niche but uh he definitely he has a
popping Community my man meal ready
individual meal number oh this is the
holy bro yeah he's the best one so this
is the American Department of defense's
best MRE uh I've actually had some to uh
I have some
I have some vets in my community I have
a a combat medic from Iraq who sent me
his MREs I've done a I've literally done
like a MRE review myself yeah back in my
MRE Heyday when I used to watch Steve
all the time
and uh I almost died as well it was
really [ __ ] up my ears wasn't rotten
was it no it was definitely rotten oh it
was yeah okay so let's I just want I'm
curious now not quite as much he just
has like a beautiful voice there's a
coffee creamer and sugar out love that
for him
this is like an ASMR quality to it as
well absolutely and he and he like truly
loves what he does and he is like very
knowledgeable on what he does
ooh that's coffee
uh no I think it's hot chocolate maybe
like cocoa powder or no protein drink
[ __ ] I mean these so there's like really
interesting technology there's like
really interesting self-heating
technology with this too yeah those are
cool I've seen those breadsticks yummy
on its own oh did he squirt the cheese
on those yeah hold on I gotta see that
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah let's [ __ ] go
right now those things are starting to
be up here I'm hungry for three of the
four breadsticks and then the gum that's
great we can try one just a little
aftertaste clean your mouth add a little
bit left jalapeno cheese spread it blows
bacon cheese spread and standard plain
cheese spread right out of the water he
loves it truly
oh look at him dumping it in the coffee
oh nice
followed up with a sip of this chocolate
person this man is out of his mind oh
wow he hasn't uploaded in three months I
noticed I think well he had died no no
no he takes a while to he really
he he takes some time our videos
possibly to recover medically after
everything yeah how much time does he
need he just [ __ ] eats it the
funniest part about it is that like even
the good [ __ ] is like us wait wait wait
is this the Pizza no that's the that's
the jalapana oh it might be yeah is that
the [ __ ] Pizza wait I don't know
because I saw it's a pepperoni pizza
review
he put the blueberry cobbler and the
pizza together he heated them up
together which is genius yeah that's
smart this is the pepperoni pizza let's
go
freshly heated up but his greatest stuff
is when he eats like nasty [ __ ] not like
when he eats good [ __ ] this is the best
this is I think this is the best ration
that the US military offers chunks so
this this is known to be everyone's fave
yeah okay interesting I had the
spaghetti bolognese it was [ __ ]
garbage but mostly because it smelled
really weird places
that straight up doesn't look that
different from the pizza that we had uh
in the school cafeteria growing up here
in Los Angeles well it looked exactly
like that you're right and by the way
there's no rotting there's no rotting on
it
what was that that is so as a blueberry
cobbler I bet that [ __ ] is dank though
you're crazy I bet that one is the
blueberry cobbler are you kidding me I
think it looks dank in like the
traditional stuff of course this is like
packed with sodium and insanely heavy in
in carbs like these are like 3 000
calorie meals because they're just like
loaded up with carbs I love that keep
the soldiers light on their feet yeah no
you got [ __ ] yeah because
they're they're they got like 70 pound
uh gear on all the time in the middle of
the desert like they're they're just
trying to they're just trying to get him
cranked up as hard as they can
wow wow he's this wait what's here turn
it better than some frozen pizza out
there oh my God he's blowing it into it
oh he loves he loves this [ __ ] this man
has had attacked from the Civil War look
that up I'm telling you that's not even
a joke so wait he actually likes the
food though is that the thing yeah he's
had like he's had like World War II he's
even had like I think he even tried like
the German World War II uh he's tried
everything and he can't know you put it
in the microwave or the oven
it'll burn before it melts little pieces
of pepperoni oh yeah speaking of pizza
yeah would you rather eat that MRE or
one of these poppable have you heard
about what the [ __ ] Papa has put
together the dream for people like you
who are in Taquito and just you know
avoiding carbs right they says let's
make the pizza without the bread and put
it in a bowl I think it's genius do they
not know what that looks like like is
the Papa John's franchise now like their
marketing team is just papa no he's gone
that's probably the company's falling
apart bro yeah they need to they need to
hire people that say the n-word all the
time that was their key to success
listen the man knows a thing or two
about pies uh you know he taught us a
lot he came on the show years ago and
um there was a lot to learn yeah
oh you didn't know he's like a friend of
the show he came on the show and we came
like best friends he was texting me all
the time and [ __ ] number
but he got he was starting to send me
Candace Owen videos and [ __ ] and I was
like wait really oh yeah oh that's
awesome I was like I don't know if I can
go down there this is one of the good
ones Ethan I love watch her I told you
that right yeah yeah yeah no he texts
you with that kind of stuff all the time
right that's that's fire yeah I did not
know that but he's a good guy I like
Papa would you eat this though he's a
good guy he is he's a good I I endorse
Papa John's everything he has said in
the past and everything he will in the
future say accept him I accept him as a
person yeah he's loved unconditional
he's Italian I mean enough being [ __ ]
pies that I can't say [ __ ] really I Papa
John used to slam hard back in the day
oh he was a speaker at CPAC bro yep oh
what do you mean you say the n-word you
get canceled immediately the Republican
party is like that's art yeah
is that he came on a show and he's like
this is a huge conspiracy I never said
that and we're like okay I was starting
to get interested in a story
and he was like I'm trying to get the
transcript
I'm gonna prove my innocence this is a
huge uh conspiracy between this
marketing company and people who are
trying to oust me
guy Richie I believe was his arch
nemesis right I still remember the the
Richie wait it was something like that
something Richie it was something Richie
and you kept calling him Judas guy
Richie is a director so yeah
one of my favorite directors it's Pizza
Judas but anyway
um he kept promising this huge reveal
and we kept being like yo where's the
documents where the documents and the
reveal was just him saying the n-word
more than once yep to be honest with you
it kind of didn't help that was the Day
of Reckoning was it yeah yeah kind of
backfired there by saying it right now I
love Papa though
Papa's in the house that man makes a
mean pie and I just you know what I mean
that is the I think it's more offensive
that you're saying that his pizzas are
good rather than oh stop rather than
defending him I would rather you defend
him on the grounds of like free speech
or whatever that didn't [ __ ] defend
the piece I'm sick of pretending like
his ties aren't good I mean pies are
[ __ ] barely edible the garlic sauce
eat a Papa John's Pizza without the
garlic sauce I dare you all the time
that's wild insane let me finish but
then again I'm saying it's gone downhill
but when he was in charge those pizzas
used to slap hard bro but to be fair you
are also I think the only like uh rich
person I know that still eats frozen
pizza like like there dude it's just
like you don't want to wait like an hour
to get your pie also I'm outside a
delivery range for like every pizza spot
that's not true there is one there's one
at uh in the village that could
definitely uh get you some like closest
the New York style pizza what yeah
there's a place in the village also
drive and you grab it The Village at
UCLA Village oh yeah
there is a place that like
is really good in the Westfield right
there is that there is there's a couple
good places in the in the west side
there's a couple good places in West
Hollywood I don't know why you have to
sell classes about it sometimes
sometimes frozen pizza has sustained
people through hard difficult and hard
times and myself included in that yeah
but you wouldn't eat it for like
personal consumption on a Tuesday
afternoon when you feel I don't know why
you'd be in such a class just about this
I mean you know bourgeoisie about this
oh 100 you know that looks like the [ __ ]
he's eating no I don't eat that [ __ ] oh
now you're being classes
because we're talking about the one type
of food that is like virtually
impossible to make like super fans like
the difference between you know
artisanal Pizza that you get from a a
shop versus like uh the the one the
microwavable version is like what
[ __ ] five extra dollars by the way
this is my boy that man is having a good
ass time the ball game oh [ __ ] look at
the mouse and Papa's in the house and
furthermore
his arch nemesis is named Steve Richie
she is the most Italian man
his house is like the most Italian house
I've ever seen his house is [ __ ]
insane dude yeah no it's that's like bro
I I went to Rutgers like that's
literally just like every [ __ ] New
Jersey upper middle class to like
wealthy I think he has the most
expensive house in Kentucky or something
yeah can you believe how much money you
can make selling pizzas most expensive
most expensive house in Kentucky so what
what is like two hundred thousand
dollars
yeah no it was it's like 10 or 20. I'm
kidding a 10 million dollar house in
Kentucky is literally like as expensive
as our barricaded uh Studio 20 billion
and by the way where's the one where he
eats the Civil War one that's what I'm
looking for here just just look up just
look up Civil War just uh no no no go go
to the bro come on send it to me why do
you embarrass me you guys just send the
[ __ ] you know you know how to click
on the the the thing
no they'll do it they'll do it welcome
to my Chris here I got it look up hard
tax let's [ __ ] go yeah Papa's Got a
question Jesus Christ okay bro that is
God damn that is so crazy
it's a clock
that's so funny he's wearing a shirt
that says Papa by the way Papa's in the
house love that hey he's got the he's
got the boot cut
love that so okay here's the Civil War
um
rations to get to the point on this one
would you eat that Papa Bowl though no
you wouldn't even try it no what okay
this is not a joke this man ate a civil
war heart attack oldest cracker ever
eaten 1863 miles that's it he eats that
[ __ ] dude look at that
okay but that's not even packaged like
you're just all right we got a really
special one this time holy [ __ ] where
you get this from like a museum yeah
like bro you're not supposed to eat this
is a wrap yeah my man goes to the Louver
and he's like or we're gonna you know he
goes to a museum and he's like yummy
yeah check that out dude it's excavated
from a hot site in Eastport Missouri
this is a large calorie oh he literally
took this he took this from a [ __ ]
grave okay my man went gray Robin
respect what is the uh
what is the historical value of eating
this
aren't just [ __ ] content like what do
you mean yes it's not food anymore it's
like a fossil these are going to be
donated to the military ration Museum
eat it oh you're not eating it [ __ ] boo
eat it very good well what is heart
attack anyway
it's a thick cracker made of flour water
and occasionally some salt when properly
stored it'll last for years all right
shut up and eat it old school
that is like
from 1860s 150 years old yeah it's
awesome that's more than a few years and
he always uses like Pitchfork or
something he has like his military uh
like he'll he'll use like an authentic
plate like a military play from the time
right it's I love him he's just he's
this is this is a [ __ ] that we could get
him to call in and look to hear from him
all right here we go buckle up man he's
[ __ ] Jack safe to say this is
probably the oldest cracker ever eaten
All-American eating history one ration
at a time let's go boy
crunchy
oh really crunchy
bro that's just dust he's just he's just
mothballs I was about to say he's just
he's just inhaling dust at that point
oh my God it tastes like races basically
just sediment at this point it tastes
like Papa John's Pizza without the
garlic sauce that's what it tastes like
milk like that
I don't know you're not gonna finish it
water smells weird all right no he just
dropped this what's he drinking he said
the water smells weird what do you get
150 year old water too no but I think uh
I think that that might be like a cup
from like that might be an arrow
appropriate cup as well yeah that water
doesn't look right
oh I think he dumped it in there and
that's why he's like trying to make it
palatable now it actually tastes worse
it tastes like rubber
kind of what so so he has gotten very
ill before he said yeah I think there's
speculation that he got really ill on on
one of the like there was but I do he
was gone for longer than he normally is
for a while and people were speculating
that he got like botulism and had to go
to the hospital or something I think he
talked about it too I just can't find it
wow shout out my man
a little bit of a cop-out not eating
this to be honest but okay I mean that's
like a historical artifact [ __ ] that
thing eat it I I agree he should have
like at least give it a little lick you
know what I mean taste it just a little
just a little tip of the tongue well so
there's that I'm so sorry that you don't
won't taste the poppable I feel that's a
portrayal but this comment I think
summarizes your stance this was under
the Twitter post thank you that makes
super convenient now you could just
throw up right in the poppable after
you've choked down this garbage
yeah what you're why are you wait why
are you making fun of the papa boy I
thought you were gonna I was saying it
echoes your
your opinion there's a lot of haters out
there who don't trust the papa listen
okay so you want to talk about uh my
conversation I had yesterday with uh
Gideon yeah with witty and Wendy and
yeah witty and W he gave Dan a new
nickname Wan Wan W Dan nice so did you
guys ever meet so uh Gideon is this guy
who recently made a video about me
he's talked about you at Great length as
well yeah he called me a liberal racist
what do you say do you say what do you
say about me he talks [ __ ]
no no he didn't no
no he didn't he's a big dude is he how
big is he pretty big I mean there's a
there's a photo of us out there uh
together we because he was at twitch
kind of you he like snuck in to do a
video Gideon and Hassan you think
that'll pop up
probably
um
I loved it the one day that my my
monitor is not working there's so much
going on that I could pull oh I mean
here here's the closest I mean
no
yeah I kicked him out personally I was
like get out of here
yes so anyway anyway since I was I was
uh
he said I'm a liberal racist and um I
showed you the thumbnail he made got him
I texted it to you I was like yo what
the [ __ ] bro yeah that was that was
inappropriate that was really what
Hassan said was pretty funny
you said what did I say
I said thank God you said that Ethan
someone had to say it
no no and I didn't say it
wait where the [ __ ] we talk this much
what
I'm sorry what the [ __ ] was that I'm
just surprised we text this much oh what
the [ __ ] we talk this much
oh [ __ ] yeah here it is
it
said uh
oh [ __ ] it's still up more
it's loading anyway you said some you
were just in shock you said did he
really post that
yeah you said haha no shot he posted
that
I said well he did look at him act like
an orangutan he's put a text bubble on
my mouth well anyway yeah I called into
the show yesterday
and um you were asking how it went I
think it went it could have gone better
so what so I I wasn't able to watch it
unfortunately because like uh I only saw
highlights of some of the things you
said during that interview on your
Reddit and I didn't know I didn't have
the the time stamps but um yeah he
called you a liberal races I mean there
are definitely a lot of races liberals
like he's not wrong I asked him to
explain you know how I was being a
liberal racist and it seemed to boil
down to the fact that
me saying he went there unprepared is
patronizing of him as a black man and
they said well is it possible for any
black person
to
be unprepared for that just by the
nature of them being black and I don't
think he ever gave a adequate answer to
that but he thinks it's not my place to
say he was unprepared even though the
KKK does not like Jewish people either
yeah so I do feel like I have an equal
stake in that except for when the when
the clients were like yeah we want to do
Israel but but for the whites
that's what he said
um yeah no they're they are not too fond
of of uh Jewish people but I think I
think ultimately I could have done
better with the conversation the problem
was that I was trying I was really
trying to squash the beef with him so I
was trying on one hand to be nice and I
know there was one time the conversation
started getting a little combative and I
was like this isn't we're going
backwards this is what I wanted but at
the same time
I feel like I let him
say too much uncontested
but I mean overall it was fine I guess I
don't know I felt like I wasn't sure
what do you guys think I don't know I
thought you did a decent job I mean it
it was very impromptu he showed up in
our chat and left a donation was like
hey Ethan can I call in and you were
just like yeah sure [ __ ] it I'll talk to
you so we got him in there and not
really knowing what it was going to be
um some people thought he was about to
get Sam cedared with like keemstar or
something I was like I would love that
but no he came in good faith and he just
wanted to talk it out with you and yeah
I you know sure you could have done
better but I think for it just being a
spur of the moment conversation you held
yourself well and you you know you were
trying to reconcile so uh it's
understandable that you like you said
you weren't trying to make it combative
with him also it's like bro I saw
because we're having a live conversation
about like race and [ __ ] and I was like
bro I see that I can see the highlights
and the clips coming to haunt me 10
years from now oh yeah so I was like
[ __ ] optically optically it's never good
to you know be oh
you're never going to look good and it's
understandable as a white person telling
a black person about racism it's just
not going to work unless it's like I'm
talking to [ __ ] uh Jesse Lee Peterson
yeah that guy's yeah you know what I
mean and like everyone is like kind of
established that he's just ridiculous
yeah yeah
um
so yeah no and and
I don't know I I can't figure out if he
was if he is like just you know he I
originally thought he wanted to do
something serious for once you know what
I mean like I legit thought he wanted to
do something serious and he took it
seriously and then when the product came
out and there was like a little bit of
trolling in there you know what I mean
because he has to do that obviously and
then
um
and then the impact of what he did was
was obviously uh received well from his
audience who love him regardless and
they were like oh yeah
witty and you killed it
um and then some other people looked at
it and were like what the [ __ ] you're
like kind of whitewashing the KKK a
little bit
um I don't think he was like he was like
a little surprised I think a little
caught off guard by that I don't think
he really still understands the point
we're trying to make which is that like
I just don't get the point of trying to
humanize the KKK I just don't understand
the end goal of that yeah I mean I mean
Nico did a a video as well uh literally
he was there he was actually featured in
Gideon's video as well and he does stuff
like that all the time in the UK with
like the Edo and and you know he has
like a clear
political understanding of the world and
he's like trolled racist people before
many many times over and I I watched
that I watched his video as well and I
was like this is great this is super
well done that's just kind of all I
meant is that yeah he doesn't he he's
not prepared for that kind of
conversation I don't think he really got
that but at the end of the day I know
why I know that comes across as
patronizing though like I I totally
understand that
um yeah because it's like well you know
he's like
he's like I'm black you know so how dare
you tell me
uh that you know I was unprepared to
deal with the KKK right but that's not a
fair rebut to the criticism but but to
that I have to say like these guys know
how to do marketing okay they are
they're not normal people with like
genuine uh perspectives and you're like
having a normal conversation with them
if you treat it like that and not like
uh not the way that I treat like every
conservative commentator for example
um you are going to uh you're going to
be used by them and he and in my opinion
he was you know but he doesn't he he
can't he can't entertain that idea
yeah he and like you know there was one
point at the end of his video that I was
like bro what the hell he he goes would
you like to say anything to the world uh
to the KKK guy and he goes no just
thanks for listening
I was like what the [ __ ] yeah thanks for
listening I don't know
yeah I um I don't know I I just I'm
fascinated with him I we've been meaning
to do something together for a while
like make some content together for a
while uh we'll we'll figure it out I'm
trying to get him on I'm trying to I'm
trying to have a conversation with him
don't have it again uh on leftovers too
uh if he wants to do it live but uh I
can't obviously do it on Twitch
unfortunately because he's banned which
kind of sucks because
and now he'll never get on band now that
he like [ __ ] openly antagonized
twitch and like broke into twitchcon EU
and stuff
but um
well yeah ultimately it's not like he
did anything super wrong it was just
like some some like criticism there's
nothing to have beef over for anything
like that you know what I mean
but anyway shout out to the KKK I'm glad
that I we listened to them you know yeah
they have a lot to say and I just think
it's really interesting
I mean free speech Free Speech baby but
again it's like what I do not listening
to KKK I mean Society will collapse if
that happens yeah they're about their
opinion is just as valuable as anyone
else's yeah
we just want all black people to perish
okay that's interesting and what's your
response to that maybe we can find a
middle ground yeah can we compromise on
this yeah fifty percent
yeah okay but that that's it you know
if you watched it
be able to talk about it more
what
I was just joking that you didn't watch
the video oh yeah no I I'm probably
gonna watch it later
so anyway what else we got poppable uh
oh yeah you got [ __ ] you caught caught
in the crossfire of the cat controversy
oh I've always so that's really funny
because I I saw the celebrity post and I
was like what the [ __ ] going on and
from what I understand like what you are
oh that's a really old video yeah like I
I've all digging up your your biggest
controversies [ __ ] Dan crenshaw's eye
this is the real [ __ ] yeah oh no I've
been oh I finished [ __ ] can't Dan
crenshaw's eyes isn't that funny yeah
well
yeah that's like a command it's Ethan it
is it we're we're nearing the
anniversary the third uh year of 8 21 is
when I said the the things that I said
about America deserving certain things
and Dan Crenshaw and yeah and you know
we're too close I get canceled every
August yeah they bring it up every year
no no well sometimes but also
I just get like last year last year I
got canceled for the house at this
literally at 8 20. like at the same day
almost okay that's interesting well here
I'm sorry to do this too but I just have
yeah I think it's important you address
this because people are really angry
time again I'll be petting a [ __ ] cat
and then cat will decide I no longer
want to be pet literally going from
purring to [ __ ] trying to rip my
fingers off bro that's what I'm saying
dude cat owners are so psychotic dude
cat owners are so psychotic they're like
oh you didn't respect the cat no yeah
that's right no what the [ __ ] you're
literally you're doing it you touch the
No No victim blaming that's it then
again not surprising because you
literally are like you're like an abuse
victim the the if you want the apology
Podium just let me know because I dabble
I went against the cap people last week
and I regretted it oh yeah no they are
they're worse than BTS bro no they will
[ __ ] they will yeah they will dox you
they will come yeah bro
um get out of me no it's just like yeah
being good this is apology music being
in a being in a house with cats like
being in a house like a shitty roommate
you know what I mean and and toxic
toxoplas Moses is like real too but I'm
saying oh my God what haven't said that
cats are when they're when they're
giving you the love the the love that
you don't deserve you know what I mean
but when they when they have their hot
moments and they give you like
give you the little bit of love and
affection then it's pretty fire yeah but
then they claw you and like leave
scratch marks on your arm no well yeah
that's why you gotta that's why you
gotta like limit your window limit your
window of interaction with them you
leave them they don't leave you I took a
photo with Coots uh Ludwig's cat
yesterday and I squashed my beef with
cats so here's my my history with cats
is basically
all bad when I was a kid we had a cat
the previous owners like abandoned their
cat which was [ __ ] up when they moved
out obviously and uh so that cat lived
in our garage and my mom took care of it
and fed it so if it was an outdoor cat
and every time I would go out there and
try to pet that little [ __ ] [ __ ] ass
cat she would claw the [ __ ] out of me
and hiss at me yeah and me I'm a child
and I'm being abused by this cat that
I'm just trying to pet
here yes this is very cute okay yeah I
mean but this is like really good oh
he's got a little folded ears look at
him no I was really tired this was like
a 11 you know he's late at night it's so
cute I was dying a little bit but I was
like you know what this cat's really
[ __ ] cute I'm gonna pick it up
yeah and he was cool with it what and he
was cool with it he was chilling and
then he wasn't he was chill with it and
then he was like all right put me down
see I need to hold a cat or something I
need to kiss a baby yeah no don't kiss a
cat because then you might get your eye
clawed out you know what I mean but
yeah so when I was a kid there was that
and then when I was in college I had a
roommate
a housemate who had a cat and this cat
used to come into my [ __ ] room and
piss all over my [ __ ] piss all over my
[ __ ] yeah every day and then I go I got
nothing to do with that guy and then I
wake up one day
and I catch this [ __ ] cat pissing on
my [ __ ] and I grab it and I threw it out
of my room and the cat came back and
started clawing me bro Alpha
I'm like dude this [ __ ] cat [ __ ] is
not for me I'm sorry I feel you I feel
you like dogs would never do that
a dog would never do that cats are just
not like a dog would never piss all over
the place not out of not the
well-trained dog won't yes no never well
I might do that my dog is as pissed on
my bed before well yeah when he was a
puppy
I feel like it might have been out of
spite to be honest with you oh yeah he's
quite pissed no dogs dogs pipe is if you
like left him alone for a while Bernie
said a period of time and they're like
oh that's cool well I hear here's a gift
for you I know it because we we just
walked him and he went to the bathroom
and he just went home and literally went
to the bed and just pissed everywhere
yeah well that's not to sound too much
like a cat owner but like you know
that's kind of your fault I think you
probably get something whatever
anyway I saw this video on Tick Tock I
was curious what you think
this guy you know monkey pox is the new
hot holy [ __ ] this [ __ ] went to
McDonald's with monkey pox yo we're just
the drive-through I hope well yeah but
still I don't think you're supposed to
be out and about with that [ __ ] let's
see
um my bad I'm not in the house as I'm
making McDonald's wrong because
no groceries you know I have no food
but I just wanted to make this video to
remind y'all to be careful who you [ __ ]
with
cause not everybody you [ __ ] with is
gonna [ __ ] with you not everybody you
look out for is gonna look out for you
[ __ ] you might show up for the wrong
[ __ ] at the wrong place at the
wrong time and end up with the [ __ ]
monkeypox and then we're gonna be there
to look out for you nobody
so at the end of the day just choose
yourself
yeah so so I just thought it was
interesting I was like this guy went to
[ __ ] McDonald's with monkey people I
just did you just promote a song yeah
yeah yeah yeah but he's talking about
Choose Yourself I was like damn bro you
really did Choose Yourself
um monkey pox is is an interesting one
because like uh from what as far as I
understand and after covid like
now I have uh I I have a policy of just
like sitting back and not immediately
jumping to conclusions because even uh
the the
medical authorities that are in charge
might get certain things uh not fully
correct at first like with coven we were
talking about like fomide spread you
know that people were just like yeah you
need to clean your
you need to you need to like wash your
groceries you need to
bleaching hysteria yeah and and so for
monkeypox it's just been I've just been
chilling on it well it's not it's first
of all it's not
it's not as prevalent as covet it's a
lot harder to catch in that you have to
touch somebody yeah or touch a surface
that was recently touched by someone
with monkey pox but I'm saying this
dude's handing a credit card if I knew
someone in a drive-through is handing me
a credit card covered in Monkey pox I
don't know bro that's not really dope
yeah and the problem is like
I feel like the CDC just announced that
they're going through a reorganizing uh
like this week
because they feel as though they have
not
they have not done an adequate job of
tackling Healthcare uh crises like
epidemics and whatnot which they really
haven't
um but also simultaneously they they did
this a week after the CDC was like yeah
covid at schools if you get it who cares
YOLO yeah you know kids who just have
covet it's fine
um now that's of course different than
saying that last year or two years ago
because we didn't have Pax livid we
didn't have like actual adequate
treatment mechanisms for covid and we
didn't have a a mass inoculation
campaign well and also there was a
[ __ ] window in the beginning where we
could have uh
stopped it well let's not forget that
that was actually an achievement
technically covered zero could have
happened but like look at China you know
what I mean they they have a very strict
coveted zero policy and they still are
maintaining that Code Zero policy but
because they successfully did that while
the rest of the planet was like you know
locked down shut down going crazy they
were able to literally open up water
parks and [ __ ] right
um
Australia yeah and their GDP didn't
suffer as a consequence of that they
continued uh you know their regular
order of business but now whenever covet
does pop up in areas uh they undergo
super super rigid super rigorous uh and
and really crazy shutdowns well listen I
the way I see it is China did its part
okay in that regard and the United
States almost singularly [ __ ] the
whole world with this [ __ ] by literally
doing nothing about it yeah everyone
else most of the Western World just did
not care about it or did not offer for
adequate protections
to its citizens for sure but I actually
cut out monkey pox listen I made you
this you did you were left out or you
felt you were feeling left out from by
um
when you you made me no but our BFF
Gathering you know we touched on but now
we have our own friendship bracelet
Hassan heart Ethan it's really beautiful
it is beautiful and by the way I'll tell
you as a token of friendship to you this
one is way [ __ ] nicer than the one
they got true oh hell yeah yeah [ __ ] you
wait they got break I didn't even know
they got bracelets yeah they have what
this is how I'm finding out that they
even got braces that's messed up and now
you have nothing to be upset about okay
it's cool but this one's got like little
bling [ __ ] on it yeah very beautiful so
thank you this is starfish yeah and feet
what there's it's a cow hoof no there's
oh it's feet yeah no that's human feet
on it human feet that's cool foot
soldiers
right
yeah I just wanted to you know
make a a meaningful gesture to you
there's my friend as my bestie okay and
um
you I mean if you you want to say
something in return thank you okay thank
you very much I feel I feel loved okay I
feel appreciated okay anything else
specifically about me maybe
what am I supposed to oh I don't know
just fishing for compliments no you're
wonderful you're great you're kind
awesome thank you bro you have a great
heart thanks bro you too even though you
are liberal racist [ __ ] God
we're not all perfect no yes so okay
let's get on with the the head stories
that Crowder Steven Crowder the big I
mean I don't know if he's the biggest
piece of [ __ ] but he's up there and he
might be
I hate Matt Walsh more maybe than
Crowder yeah Matt Walsh is worse than
Crowder yeah but Stephen Crowder got
suspended again he tweeted out
this was just this morning eh is it
today's the 17th yeah or yesterday
yesterday yeah wow we won't be able to
stream to YouTube because comments from
a current goober goober now
candidate Kerry Lake in Arizona
would you find it I mean goober they're
really going to go out there with that
it is a weird word for sure I like it
though I like that it's weird yeah on a
show so he says this candidate came on
uh is this isn't suppression of
politicals if this isn't suppression of
political speech then nothing is see you
on Rumble and the mug Club This Is War
this is like the third time he's
declared war no I mean he's really not
backing up the war declarations at this
point no because war is just he keeps
saying war and then he's like oh what
are you gonna do and he's like oh just
uh you know subscribe to my mug Club
yeah that's War for him Wars check out
my War plan at Mud Club he's going he's
going to war with Pottery Barn every
[ __ ] week
yes so anyway he says our team has
reviewed your content unfortunately we
think it violates misinformation policy
we removed it we have uh so so who I
watched the clip and it's so obvious why
he got [ __ ] busted can we play it
while doing commentary we can play it if
we're if we like I really from a
newsworthy standpoint we're like this is
misinformation we're not covering this
or talking about it we're simply we're
showing this from a newsworthy
perspective I love that and obviously
this and also for YouTube sensors this
[ __ ] is crazy yeah so the thing is like
if if Steven Crowder did what you did
I'm sure he wouldn't have had would have
been trouble with YouTube if he was like
Hey even if he was like saying it
because he knows he knows that there are
strict guidelines around this because he
brings it the [ __ ] up every goddamn time
he's got in trouble for it yeah every
time he gets every time he's on and he
has to say something about the election
or say something about Kobe he'll always
be like well because our YouTube
overlords don't want us to say anything
truthful or whatever like he always has
to clarify it so why didn't he do it in
this circumstance is what I well you can
you can even tell like uh the thing is
he's been warned about this he's
probably been in trouble about this it
YouTube handles Crowder with the kitty
gloves he should have been banned so
many strikes ago the reason he's not is
because he's one of the you know handful
of popular conservative commentary
people there's a lot of them on YouTube
especially there's like a handful of
really popular ones like Crowder Tim
Poole Ben Shapiro that these Cancun's so
if they like permanently ban him it's
just I don't think they want to deal
with that [ __ ] storm so I think he gets
up no conservances are the best they cry
bullying like they will literally
go crazy I mean they effectively turned
Facebook into like uh the white
supremacist Hub it is yeah by one
lobbying Facebook two having uh you know
the Heritage Foundation and other like
right-wing reactionary think tanks
actually do the regulation mechanism
okay and then three by going to the
media and crying and saying Facebook is
like Banning conservatives over and over
again and effectively they turned
Facebook into the Cesspool that it
actually is yeah so YouTube if you want
your content to look like Facebook if
you want your platform to turn into meta
if you want to if you want it to be so
bad uh if you want your platform to play
a actual legitimate role in like I don't
know uh furthering the uh genocide of
Muslims the rohingya Muslims in in Burma
or in Myanmar then you know go off allow
this kind of thing to happen and be
bullied by right-wing reactionaries who
want to do Nazi commentary on your
platform yeah and promote our podcast
for Christ's sake yeah that's for sure
the good guys they're the baddies yeah
anyway here's the clip also This Woman's
running for governor and uh Arizona is
she leading is she doing oh yeah oh
she's gonna oh yeah no Arizona's one of
the bat [ __ ] [ __ ] craziest politics
of anything to be fair to be fair it's
like 107 degrees I think it melts
people's brains like literally yeah
uh this lady is absolutely nuts I don't
believe anything she's saying she this
is misinformation it's not true and
she's nuts that's for you YouTube it's
important for our Representatives
Governor centers everyone to try and
apply pressure to Republicans with
national influence to spend the FBI to
make sure that we reduce the scope of
the IRS can I just point out what a
giant [ __ ] colossal [ __ ] Stephen
Crowder is the man has holsters he's
wearing his shirt it says fight like
hell he's declaring war every day and
you do nothing [ __ ] try something I
want to clarify something by the way
some [ __ ] I want to clarify something so
Carrie uh so Kerry Lake uh is a former
uh local news Legend all right like
she's like a well-known figure as a
local news anchor
um she's out of her [ __ ] mind well I
I think she's faking it but she's doing
a good job faking it like you think
she's faking it why would you pretend to
be that crazy
to win an election I don't think people
do that I think she is crazy I think she
is no I think there's varying degrees of
like legitimately insane all the way
down to like like Marjorie Taylor green
is like
I would say 60 genuine 40 Faking It
Carrie like on the other hand is more 50
50. and then you have people like
um uh the one in [ __ ] the one that lost
in Georgia was it Kelly
uh I can't even remember her name now
holy [ __ ] anyway or Martha McSally even
like these are people who try to portray
themselves as like populists but they
come from the old school conservative uh
uh attitude of like you know Country
Club conservatives like they have
disdained for the poor well these guys
do too but like at least they can you
know act like uh they have the same
opinion that the the reactionary uh
Republican working-class individuals
have
whereas uh some of them are just not
very good at doing that and and then
they end up failing Carrie Lake on the
other hand is like a little bit more
genuine than others but even then I
think she's like
I don't think I don't think she's
legitimately that crazy well let's see
it's it's a litmus test for me now
100 yeah he's saying anyone who doesn't
want to
systematically and completely dismantle
the FBI if I'm not a true Republican and
by the way she's going up against Hobbes
and uh actually Hobbs is uh leading in
the polls in the gubernatorial race
what's this by like eight points okay or
or six seven points and I'm assuming
he's not crazier than her
no no no Katie Hobbs is the the Democrat
I'm saying she did she destroy the
competition in the Arizona in the
Arizona primaries recently that's what I
was talking is going to be Governor
probably
well we'll see I I think that uh
I think that the Arizona Secretary of
State Katie Hobbs uh he's in the lead
Hogs is in the lead Hobbs is in the lead
yeah I got that fat hog
yeah she she does yeah all right let's
watch this [ __ ] then I agree
um you know and we're gonna push back
with our state's rights you know we're
sovereign states we are not that's the
first thing she lost me on she says
every state is a sovereign state like um
you're gonna have a hard time with that
one
sovereign state no
I love that I'm on board
[ __ ] it dude down for Canyon I'm down
for California to be Sovereign I mean
[ __ ] no it's just it's just content at
this point I feel like first of all I
don't think it's gonna I mean obviously
I don't think it's gonna happen
regardless oh [ __ ] and um you know a lot
of what these people want is is uh I
really think it's in Pokemon sorry good
like if you're a legislator even though
she is the governor like you are maybe
the governor can say like secession
easier than other people but like even
then you rely on the federal government
for money yeah so you know also I'm sure
they're like a welfare state Arizona I'm
sure they get a lot more than they give
you know
you're not sovereign lady okay yeah they
just they they say it but they would
never do that
they like they would never actually do
that Arizona Budget Surplus has grown to
5.3 billion maybe that's why they're
acting out
let's see these issues from a state's
point of view and a state's perspective
instead of letting uh these agencies
with people who haven't been elected by
the people dictate what we should be
doing in our lives we watched the CDC
tried to destroy our lives we watch all
of these agencies with their incredible
overreach in our lives the last few
years it's been very very obvious what's
happening and uh that's one of the
reasons I think I'm doing so well people
want someone who's going to push back
against this I believe illegitimate
federal government right now with Joe
Biden in charge okay so now she makes
this comment that's somewhat General but
it's like a a nod to this conspiracy
that Joe you know Joe Biden uh did not
win the election and so watch Crowder's
response okay
yo can you clarify just to make sure
that our audience understands what do
you mean when you say illegitimate
federal government by Joe Biden
well I I don't believe I watched this
dumbass [ __ ] Grim creep of crossed
his face like ah she said it I didn't
Joe Biden won the election and we had
problems with the 2020 election I've
talked about that they've criticized me
for that but I've looked at the facts I
have looked over our friends that got it
I've looked over all kinds of evidence
and we had a box so pathetic didn't they
reach out in Arizona and it was like
multiple times multiple really fine no
colossal wasted time and money yeah it's
it's not it's not happening
corrupt election in Arizona and in many
other states and this is why it's really
important that we Round of Applause from
the whole crew damn so Stephen Carter is
going to be like hey because the YouTube
guidelines you can't actually say that
he's just like clapping okay well now
you got your ass clapped good job yeah
yeah exactly it's like shut up [ __ ]
stop whining this is exactly what you I
mean he was he was elated he's like yeah
oh yeah say it I didn't actually know
that Crowder was that crazy though that
he thinks the election was stolen no no
he's a he's a charlatan he's an actor he
doesn't believe that that's crazy right
right no he these guys don't
legitimately believe half the [ __ ] that
they say they would they would have to
be like real demons for that and uh no I
don't I don't think that that's why he
promotes the mug Club Ethan like if he
genuinely believed that like the
election was [ __ ] stolen he'd be
trying to uh you know arm the militias
yeah and storm the [ __ ] white house
every goddamn day yeah launch a
protracted people's war against the
American Federal Government yeah but
he's not doing that what is he doing
he's selling you [ __ ] mugs why is he
selling you [ __ ] mugs because that's
all he cares about that's his interest
because he knows that it's not real it
doesn't [ __ ] matter to him
ultimately though if you're one of these
dumbasses who listens to him and goes oh
yeah that's right the election was
stolen look Carrie lake is saying it
Stephen Crowder my favorite is saying it
then yeah you're you're an idiot you're
gonna turn out like uh dick [ __ ] the
guy uh the Cincinnati FBI uh hero who
[ __ ] tried to use a nail gun to
penetrate the bulletproof glass of the
FBI offices in Cincinnati like good job
you know you're gonna get [ __ ] killed
by a federal agent and then the funniest
part about that story well is that every
single [ __ ] that was in the
forums alongside he was going to say
you're an OP you're an OP you were a
federal agent oh that's fine you're
[ __ ] antifa you're you're gay sjw
antifa okay well now you're [ __ ] you
didn't even get the the you know you
didn't even get like uh the the
accolades yeah the accolades of
martyring yourself you know what's
interesting I wonder if Stephen probably
thought about this he goes well if they
go Kamikaze their credit card is
probably going to stay on autopay on the
mug club for a minute for a good minute
right yeah they won't they won't
immediately like how long do those how
long do those automatic payments go
after someone dies yeah Steven's
probably crunched the numbers on that
I'm just saying
one of my top issues to reform our
elections here in Arizona I want to make
sure that we have honest elections and
that doesn't mean we get the advantage
as Republicans shut up honest elections
yeah that's literally what you mean we
want honest elections in Arizona what
that means is uh if it's a Democrat if
you're voting Democrat we shoot you okay
you go to the poll and you're like hey
if you're not wearing you know how their
electioneering laws like you can't wear
like a political shirt to go vote yeah
and you can't petition like near a
polling station you know in Arizona
we're gonna do the opposite of that if
you're not wearing a Mega Shirt while
you're going out to vote you're not
allowed to vote it's illegal you will go
to jail yeah that's fair
it means that there is no advantage to
either side but that all voters whether
they be Democrat independent or
republican or non-affiliated really
um that they go to bed on Election night
a they know the winner we're not
counting ballots for 10 days we don't
count ballots
we could declare the winner on day one
to be fair is Arizona you know what I
mean the public education has destroyed
theirs it takes a while for them to
count
right whether so they need more than one
day
and B they feel comfortable with the
winner even if it wasn't their guy
because they know the system is honest
God you are so you guys are both such
Demons by the way here is a close-up of
our friendship bracelet yeah it's
beautiful so you guys can see The Cool
Little starfish and feet why why the
feet in the starfish I'm assuming for
foot soldier wait you didn't make this
yourself no I did I'm telling you I'm
telling you
assuming no I'm not assuming anything
the feat is for obviously foot soldiers
and wikiFeet I you know this is where my
origin story begins and the starfish for
that beautiful brown little starfish I
want to get at my my hands in
I don't know my butthole yeah yeah oh
okay Brown starfish nice I don't know
that's the I was trying to interpret
this in some way I don't have any other
one Mr [ __ ] is one keeping helping
that's what I'm talking about yeah okay
all right that Chocolate Starfish boy
okay I love that yeah so anyway so shout
out to Crowder who uh got banned and I
couldn't be happier about it suck my
dick [ __ ] you get banned idiot you asked
for it and you got it also you're a
[ __ ] where's that war at
where's that war at yeah is he I wish he
would uh you know learn his lesson and
then um not promote ridiculous
conspiracies next time around but I
don't think he's gonna you don't settle
down you don't sell mugs that way my
friend I feel like every time he gets
banned uh you know he sees a big uptick
in his mug Club subscription so he's
probably factored that in you know oh
yeah
it's just how it goes now again we talk
about Andrew yangelot There's A Yank
thing that came up I personally used to
be a big fan of Andrew Yang he was on
the show and it was real interesting to
see oh hold on uh yes so what the [ __ ]
is this yeah well Hassan you asked for
it oh this is the Papa's [ __ ] meat I
I will not be having them no shot I'm
breaking my fast well not even breaking
my fast but like how much were these
uh
they're like seven bucks a piece
you gotta get a close-up of this
I got you the meat one bro
what do you mean you're fasting oh that
looks good oh that looks so gnarly wait
oh it looks like throw up dude you know
what's funny yeah that looks horrible
that looks so funny it look this
literally looks like you ate a Papa John
Pizza without the garlic sauce which is
the only good thing there without the
garlic butter and you threw it up oh
there's water there's water that is like
that is collecting in the bottom of this
on the corner right now as I was like I
don't wanna I don't want to tilt it any
further
stay hydrated dude
I don't understand why they did this at
least it smells like a pizza kind of
there's why is there is there kale in
this there's like a there's all kinds of
veggies I got the meat special I don't
want vegetables they have some like
weird vegetable on the corner I think
there's green peppers I don't know no no
no green peppers is fine whatever the
[ __ ] this is It's like a leaf can you I
can't tell if you can see it
right there
onion maybe burned onion no that's not
an onion it's like a leaf it's like a
grape leaf or something oh
you better eat that there's no shot
don't waste food I can't I there's I I
don't feel like that you have to try it
I need to see I need to see the calorie
on this Keto
we got it for you because it's keto I'm
gonna put it back nope it's not I'm not
dude look at all the veggies inside of
this okay
let's take a look I want to see the uh
bro it is 12 p.m you're eating how are
you eating this are you enjoying it be
honest
I mean
no I would never eat this
like I would never buy this for myself
Ethan's like I would never eat this two
days in a row I'm not waiting I'm not
wasting food though like you
starving kids in Africa could eating
this yeah no I'm I'm good kind of dark
honestly no they wouldn't they lightly
die if they yeah I would not I would not
give this to them okay this is worse
than your ration bro would have eaten
this yeah Woody I don't know hey John
you're not gonna try it no I'm gonna
take a bite I'm looking out the uh Papa
bowls uh calories take a look at the
Discord real quick
um
yummy the nutritional information uh for
Papa bowls ingredients allergens weight
they don't have the macronutrients he
already did look
2002 American fupa Troopa compact
poppable 24-hour MRE food packet review
you see that yeah they drop ship it out
into karengal Valley
um
yummy if we had if we had these we would
have won in Afghanistan
our boys would have been properly uh um
properly fed
okay I can't find I cannot find the
nutritional information so by the way we
had to
they wouldn't let us buy it it's only
for their exclusive it's for VIPs only
right now wait are you [ __ ] serious
about it the Royalty Club thankfully
because of our Inn with with Papa I was
able to snag a couple VIP paths yeah so
we went to Great Lengths to get this for
you okay uh Papa John's nutritional
information says 920 calories I don't
what
you've had a papadia we actually talked
to Papa John about the papadia
I don't think I ever tried it though bro
you are are you in are you still in
constant communication with this man I'm
telling you we text we're homies
do you want me to text him something
right now you should text him right now
ask him what he thinks of the papa Bowl
I'm sending my image ask him if he knows
ask him if he knows who I am
[Laughter]
here Papa he's in my phone under pop-up
that's crazy
you should do a BFFs with him the day of
record for enemies
I have two numbers I wonder which one is
the real damn he gave you the one for
the plug and one for the hose that's
right you're the hoe you're the you're
his host he did I have both phone
numbers yeah
I think this is his personal one I'm
gonna send him a picture of this
I took a photo and I'm gonna say
I'll say
this wouldn't have you just call them
this would never have happened on your
watch
what if he likes it though what if he's
like no actually that was my idea
wait this one's green text he definitely
used an iPhone right there's no way
that's a great damn he gave you a fake
number look at the other one
I'll send them the same exact message
no I'm no shot
no shot someone tasted them I I [ __ ]
love it dude the reason why I don't want
to taste it is because look I have I eat
2 380 calories every single day okay now
all of those calories are accounted for
I'm gonna have a [ __ ] salad for lunch
I'm gonna have some chicken for dinner
just take one okay bro if I if I take
one bite out of this I'm first of all I
can't even account for it uh calorie
wise and secondly it's just not like I
try to make the correct nutritional
choices by this is eating something
delicious that I want to put in my body
it's keto bro doesn't that matter no
that doesn't matter it doesn't no
because
um like all these fat diets including
keto like all it does is still uh
operate off of the the same principle of
of calories and calories out and keto is
just one way to eliminate like a
gigantic uh you know caloric burden from
your diet I don't like how much liquid
is on the bottom I find that kind of
gross too liquidy it is like a
microwavable bowl like you know what I
mean you like this on Jack oh yeah dude
this is some [ __ ] I'd make at home
honestly I liked it until you mentioned
the liquid on bottom now I'm a little
girl style you have your own yeah yeah
where did you get your own I got the
chicken bro they're slamming the bowls
back there
you're jealous why is Dan not having any
because it's disgusting oh wow hey hey
no interest in trying that also there's
tons of although there was a uh there
was a veggie one
um Garden veggie they call it
um yeah literally from the Fresh
sidewalk yes exactly all the Shrubbery
that they were able to grab on the
sidewalk
the compost bowl yeah but um
yeah a watery bowl of melted cheese
doesn't sound like good breakfast to me
all right don't think about the water
it's not bad it's very watery why is it
watery
Ah that's not good they need to work on
the watery
all right I'm out
all right let me take it away so you
don't you can't take it please can I
have a song yeah I'm not I haven't even
touched it so you can smell it at least
put it I did I did smell it it was it
doesn't smell bad it smells like a Papa
John's Pizza like it's growing on me
hold on hold on let me let me
did you not get your own attack why is
it no dude I got snobbed oh well then
take you know take us
yo this is growing on me
I'm I'm posting it on my Ig
stop it
give Zach the rest of Ethan's I'll take
it dude
right it's actually that's all good oh
there's more majority low carb you know
that's low carb yeah
wow look at this this is amazing you
missed out dude
we were debating if you would text her
or not I thought you would I thought you
cared about me that much but
oh my God this looks amazing
it's a lot of it is onions and water
that's kind of surprised me there's so
much bell pepper and onion in there the
bowl is so bad that it's making me
reconsider uh my thoughts about all of
you
Hassan you're tripping dude this is
amazing
giving me a look I don't know I wouldn't
call it amazing doc best thing I've ever
eaten this is terrifying the fact that
you guys are all in unison saying that
this is good is alarming okay well if
you thought that was gross bring out the
papadilla
let's go
I still don't really know what that is
so let's see if Papa John gets back to
me yeah this one is the blue text this
is his real one
man that looks like a [ __ ] lasagna
that went to hell and back
it's just like it doesn't have
presentation either like right it has
nothing it's nothing good about that
yeah but so oh dude I saw that I swear I
looked right you looked at me eye
contact is like you look at it right in
the eye a piece of like squid looking
like a green thing was like
yep how do you go from eating delicious
Dearborn food to that and being like oh
this is great yeah I don't know yeah I'm
ashamed crazy that's crazy you're not
ashamed you love it admit it
that you took a bite you didn't have to
take that bite the bit's over yeah
that is long over let me get down
wherever that was
yeah I don't know
I was hungry I didn't eat breakfast so
yeah yeah yeah I'm almost done with my
Champions you're almost done yeah I've
met you like a second ago I was [ __ ]
hungry let me take a look at the chicken
one
I want to see what the [ __ ] that looks
like I got the meat one and frankly that
was the least disgust oh my God bro you
[ __ ] crushed this there's nothing
left
it literally looks like throw up it
looks like you ate chicken like you ate
like a real uh meal and then you threw
it up directly into that bowl I I don't
wanna
yo you can't say you don't like it you
literally ate that whole thing fast look
at look it's actually very uh nutritious
right Peach is very neutral look at the
squid tail right here
I'm holding up
no Zach
dude hell no like I expected this from I
expected this from Ethan because he said
he loves like prefers microwavable Pizza
not microwave you put in the oven dude
okay who microwaves Pizza I'm not that
depraved okay the moment that you open
up the oven you might as well order by
the way that's crazy dude you're such a
[ __ ] classes dude grow up yeah I mean
by the way this so I'll show you the
brands that I really like of frozen
pizzas this one is so good
it's so [ __ ] good no [ __ ] shot
dude what no shot
look at that no that looks terrible
what's important I think you say see he
was in the top right
oh he's trying Frozen oh what did he
what did he say about it yeah this one I
can't say I like but here let's see what
part noise thought about it
one bite you know the rules everybody
knows okay well let's just cut to the
chase huh yeah get to the get to the
most watched part all right
there's a thousand percent better than
yesterday whoever gave me Amy's is
pretty good that's what I'm saying
Amy slap
take it back Asana
this man is compromised bro he no longer
he is betrayed he's betrayed the values
of of the Tri-State okay this is this is
the worst thing that I've ever seen this
is worse than 0.4 6.4 6.4 that's a great
score that's a great score Amy
there you have it
[ __ ] I mean first of all he's literally
wearing a cut sleeve hoodie okay
automatic L anyone you're the one that
told me to look at it anyone that wears
a [ __ ] sleeveless hoodie or a cut
sleeve hoodie I'm not listening to you
okay I'm just another one that's kind of
crazy what is Trader Joe's
frozen pizza you're oh my God these ones
are kind of crazy these ones go kind of
hard and nuts the veggie ones well this
one's insane spinach and ricotta it's
[ __ ] Frozen this one's insane yeah
insane like insane that if people are
eating it that's how insane it is
you know what I do is I'll cut up some
olives and put extra cheese on top so I
make it like special dude you are
literally my dad oh my God my dad does
that this one's not good you want to
know what else he does though that's
like real [ __ ] nasty anchovies he
loves anchovies on pizza he will get
like canned Anchovies and he put it on
Frozen yo this is the best one the pesto
Pizza is [ __ ] insane and I dare you
to I dare you bro pesto huh to death to
fame that pizza I'm not I'm not touching
it yeah but the way I see it is like
pizza is a beautiful experience okay and
uh I have no self-control if I eat pizza
even a little bit I will not be able to
stop I'll eat the entire thing and uh if
I'm going to do that I'd rather you know
because the calories are going to be the
same no matter what so I would much
rather have really [ __ ] order when
you order pizza it's way heavier I love
pizza way heavier I love people it
depends where you get it yeah but I'll
tell you what man you're dead wrong
about this this [ __ ] is insane you are a
name on you someone throwing up in the
bathroom I think so babies yeah is he
acting no way is he really he might be
brushing his teeth because he
he brushes his teeth this man
what oh no way is he really puking it
sounds like let me go that's not schtick
he actually went there and puked dude I
just downed it I mean this isn't the
first time he's Zach how are you he's
got a I feel alive fantastic
he might be brushing his teeth because
he's
is he choking if he's brushing his teeth
that's a bit much to go during the live
show to brush your teeth he always gags
when he does it yeah what kind of gag
reflex is that is that he sounds like
he's
he sounds like the toothbrush is throat
[ __ ] him
here what happened what
he was loving it and he how do you go
from loving it yeah he invited me to
look at it it looks exactly the same
actually you know what would be
interesting Olivia is out I forgot
Olivia has like a throw-up phobia can we
scoop it out of the toilet and then try
to return it and see if they take to see
if they notice the difference
oh my God send a picture to Papa okay
wait we got a debrief here I need AV
back I feel like Zach when he when when
he posted it when he put it up there was
no water which implies that he drank it
I just don't how did he go from loving
it to puking it out that fast I don't
know
I'll be honest with you most of these
pizzas suck like this [ __ ] sucks hard
because you're no [ __ ] sucks so bad
uh Rising crows how do they do there's
that's too much technology dude but some
slap man I'm not even gonna [ __ ] you
with you no I'm I'm good I'm good on
that I'm gonna I'm gonna stay
have you ever had Tony's hey it's Tony
that looks awful come on it's 100 real
why do you have to clarify that yeah
hey it's Tony's fine Pizza
yeah this is disastrous you come to the
supermarket and you don't pick dummies
after all I've done for the pizza game
this is it this is the most
disrespectful thing that they've done to
Italians like you know Columbus Day uh
uh destroyed that's one thing but like
this this is actually a desecration of
Italian values is This Racist would you
say this is 100 is this genocide and
they would yeah this is cultural
genocide being done to Italians and I
will not stand for it dude where's AV I
gotta ask him what the [ __ ] back there
on some this man is puking out the
Papa's Famous Pizza Bowl right he's
recovering still oh he's still yakking
yeah well I hear him washing his hands
yeah I think he's washing his hands so
oh so let's stop all right let's get
back to Andrea speaking of vomit yeah
that was a good one this is a great
Segway yeah so Andrew Yang's been kind
of getting blasted by everybody lately
because he's just been saying some dumb
[ __ ] like he recently said oh yeah he
about abortion rights he was like does
the is the forward party Pro
uh choice and he goes the forward party
the Ford party is doesn't stand for
anything we are we are in favor of
whatever is the common sense
consensus they're like are you do we
have that clip I don't know
dunked on him pretty hard dude it was so
satisfying all right I'm gonna BYU play
that real quick yeah it's this one right
here yet uh if you check on ABS check in
the bowl for me
use a bathroom on the left the sun I'm
gonna wait for her son but oh papa
responded wait Papa responded
he's responded
Papa said lull unbelievable and it's my
name on the door wow yo this is a
desecration you're right he would have
never let that happen I'm gonna say one
of my guys ate it and legit just puked
just puked
not even kidding I have I have a picture
if you want oh you're back what happened
I puked but you were fine and then
you I just [ __ ] into it would be in
love in it and then you went I I don't
know you got nauseous that fast
yeah a little bit so this is the pizza
if I ate too fast or what or whatever
that was you got nauseous real fast and
you had to run emergency everyone else
feels fine I feel fine I feel like a new
man I didn't eat yours yours looked
nastier than mine it looked exactly the
same
I said one of my guys ate it and legit
just puked not even kidding
you wanna see a picture Ethan I'll see a
pic yeah I'll take a look at it send the
picture Papa too
dude Papa's such a g for responding to
me you know that's what I'm saying
Papa's a [ __ ] man bro
dude that's disgusting get that on my
face
is this covered I want to see it
ow a nice looks like a log it looks the
picture looks worse but in person it
looked exactly the same as when I ate it
that's horrific so how do you rate that
bull then after all that time one bite
everyone knows the rules and uh I don't
know not not too good it was a one and
done for me
I would like to see Dave pork noi uh
rate that on the pizza scale
yeah I mean for me what I just ate is
probably I don't know at the two or
three probably
um
yeah papa responded it son
he said lull unbelievable and it's my
name on the door
that's what I'm saying where you can't
you can't disparage Papa he's a friend
of the show
he is a [ __ ] Legend
maybe we can get him to uh get us
tickets to CPAC next year we can do some
in-person reporting I would love to do
that I would love to go with him yeah
I'd love to be I would love to Squad up
with Papa and CPAC
yeah Journey hopefully that way I could
like also ensure protection he's mobbed
up that's Papa John text me back and
that's the power of this show so much
[ __ ] lore we have I love that I'm
just saying I got pop on speed dial
let's like that
you okay uh maybe
uh yeah I'm good you have any questions
for ab
S I just I don't even know what to say
hey
what happened you you had that little
[ __ ] uh green thing coming up coming
down your chin and you were like what am
I doing right now yeah I think when we
locked eyes I realized
how disgusting I looked it all made
sense at that moment I wondered if I if
it made you want to puke me showing the
empty bowl if there was some
psychological thing there no you're like
what have I done no it's like it's like
uh I throw up if like someone else is
throwing up I hate throwing up
um I feel like it's kind of like that he
saw the empty bowl which looked like
throw up so he thought you know oh it's
throw up time by the way I gotta pee now
so oh yeah keep it going oh yeah I'll
keep it going all right so should we
watch the Andrea clip okay we're not
watching the Andrea and clip we're
waiting we're waiting for Ethan all
right who's also now gonna throw up
hopefully
wait actually I don't know I hope he's
not gonna throw up I hope he's only
going to you know quick iron stomach did
he down the whole thing uh I took it
away
he didn't go to the bathroom
what are you doing
look at this [ __ ]
that's insane that that after that
Legend you looked at the picture of
Amy's throw up
I need me some more of that
bro put that down you're putting it down
Amen brother
well do you actually have to pee or did
you just want to eat that I think he's
bullshitting
is that ab's puke or is that
possible he's eating that after scene
that would have been bad a picture of
your vomit Hasan you wanna see the
picture no I don't want to no he just
said I know yeah I already saw that I
already saw it when it was on the plate
right right yeah it looked pretty much
the same
oh
I still feel it I don't know it's weird
it's in my stomach I usually I don't
react to stuff when I see it usually
it's
internal I mean you had like the Alfredo
one yeah oh yeah some 10 a.m like
Alfredo bowl with a bunch of melted
cheese on an empty stomach yeah boys the
office where Michael Scott went running
after he had Alfredo got a carb up y'all
wanted me to eat that that's crazy dude
that's I mean holy I'm glad you used to
you you stood by your principles you
said by your morals you didn't pave to
peer pressure the only thing I put in my
body the only thing I put in this body
which is a temple is ninja cotton candy
G fuel you know what I'm saying yeah
only the highest quality
um
we actually we do have more I believe we
have like a stockpile somewhere because
they sent us like five crates of that so
don't worry I want something to be
another one wait for you next week
we could send some home with you or I
don't know maybe maybe you know I saw a
crossover line here
I can't have too many of these bad boys
like I can regulate the caffeine with
like regular coffee but when it comes
down to energy drinks I feel like it
just it makes my face warm and stuff but
this one doesn't but some of them do
I can't have more than one and I I think
am I right in that it's sugar-free yeah
it is yeah all right zero calories 140
milligrams of caffeine
um
unlike uh what whatever the [ __ ] is in
the Papa John's I they won't even have
they don't even have the macronutrients
on the website yeah
the Shady is that even legal don't they
have to tell you what
nutrition facts
but John what do they call it the papa
Bowl Papa yeah the poppable big papa
are we gonna we're gonna be so we're
gonna do Andrew Yang uh we're gonna look
at injuryang forward party uh and then
afterwards we're gonna look at Dr Oz's
in a campaign in Pennsylvania right oh
that sounds good to me and that's it uh
probably basically I will do I will do
the political Spectrum test uh today
okay and we can look at the results next
week okay okay all right Ethan did his
and I I don't want to give any spoilers
but I was a little surprised by his
results wait you were just a little bit
I would have thought it was I would have
guessed somewhere slightly different on
the chart like not in like the I say
Target door spoil it don't spoil the top
right not neo-nazis yeah yeah
um there by the way we have two separate
toilets in case anyone thinks we're
pissing in his puke
also they flush
I would have yeah I'm still I mean it
splashes I don't want to be where you
just puked I don't want to piss there
all right let's do it but she's like yo
don't use that toilet let's do it let's
look at injury in because I you know you
guys gotta go so Andrew Yang uh anyway
he tweeted this out he says
then we'll watch the video he says if we
stay falsely divided by the media into
two camps we clash and clash and nothing
gets done but if a new Dynamic emerges
Real Change Is Possible and here as you
can tell based on this chart
is possible with three parties it makes
a triangle
which I guess is pointing forward you
know what I feel like I feel like back
in the day
uh on YouTube there was like the the rap
craze like everybody would do everybody
was trying to be a rapper and then it
turned into like the boxing uh fad you
know what I mean and they didn't like
genuinely care about boxing or rapping
they just like knew that it was popping
so they wanted to get in on the way
right they wanted to ride it and now I
feel like political campaigns are that
exact same thing if you want to be a
[ __ ] MSNBC commentator or something
if you want to be an analyst if you want
to sell a couple books and make some
money you have to be
out there in the media uh acting like
you are going to run for office right
and
and if you don't have a real platform
which none of these people do obviously
I mean the Democratic party barely has
one
um what you have to do is just get owned
all the time because if you get owned
all the time then you're in the media
all the time people are going to
constantly talk about you and I think
that that is what Andrew Yang's strategy
is well he already works for CNN doesn't
he yeah like that's what I mean he's not
honestly and earnestly trying to become
a politician he's not trying to make any
sort of meaningful change he's just
trying to go back on The Joe Rogan
Experience
um you know I just I don't know I met
him and I really I really actually
believed he was genuine oh you got first
you got big papa papa John now Andrea
Papa you have you have a lot of
[ __ ] on speed dial where I'm
like damn well Papa's a good guy okay
here but anyway here this is when I
realized that Andrew kind of is just a
big [ __ ]
grifter I mean this [ __ ] is just
unforgivable watch this [ __ ]
come up with policies
yeah but Andrew you're gonna have to
have policy positions at some point how
does the forward party feel about Roe
versus Wade should it have been
overturned easy one right well I I
personally uh think that women's
reproductive rights are fundamental
human rights but the forward party has
not left or right but forward stands on
even the most divisive and contentious
like there's a I think is a fundamental
right for women okay and the forward
party believes in protecting that
fundamental right he can't even say that
he's like but the forward party takes a
forward stance on it what the [ __ ] does
that mean he really thinks that he's
appealing to conservatives by saying
that I mean bro what are you doing you
just so pathetic right here I mean he
gets eviscerated um even the most
divisive and contentious issues don't
you have to take a position on something
you don't have to take a position on
something you can't just say well I you
know this is a hot button issue so I'm
not going to take a position on you you
know you want to run the country you're
going to have to make some hard
decisions Andrew
again the forward party is about that
Common Sense consensus majority view
which is very clear on abortion it's
clear what about guns what about assault
weapons climate change it's actually
clear on just about every issue Under
the Sun should 18 year olds so why are
you the forward party then like you then
you're just what the programming party
because
most Progressive policies have
overwhelming popular majority it doesn't
make any sense I mean ironically you
said Democrats because yes he is a
Democrat he's just a Democrat being the
Centrist position on uh all of these
issues is what the Democratic party does
they are so desperately center-seeking
all the time uh as the Republican party
goes further and further right so why
did this guy just make like the second
Democratic party it is that's holiday
there's no reason for that he's trying
he thinks he's clever because he doesn't
have to endorse any specific thing he
just goes hey whatever the people want
I'm down yeah okay like great great
question I would have asked him in this
situation is like okay what about civil
rights
that was not only contentious but also
the broad consensus majority opinion on
civil rights was that segregation should
continue and it should be left up to the
states what do you think about that
that's a perfect one well uh you know I
believe that black Americans should have
the right to vote but uh the forward
party believes in the common sense
consensus which is to yeah
like that was that was because that was
it that was like he had a he had 67 of
the country in the aftermath uh uh
thought that like you know Martin Luther
King was a bad guy did the Civil Rights
Movement was bad there should have been
no there there should have been no
legislation
yeah he doesn't want the KKK guy from
Gideon's vid to feel left out of the
process yeah well those guys are well
represented in politics anyway you know
what I mean that's the Republican party
that's very true so anyway here's Yang
uh changing the world this forward
party's happening
because of the nature of our system
should 18 year olds be able to buy
AR-15s
again the common sense consensus
majority is that there should be some uh
rules or you're such a [ __ ] [ __ ]
just you're such a loser in this moment
dude I'm telling you Tulsi gabbard did
this [ __ ] too it's like I mean she she
just went straight right wing but
um these guys are trying to reorient
themselves because American politics is
mostly American politics mostly revolves
around Aesthetics and for that reason
you can very easily uh put on a new skin
and and decide like I've reinvented
myself I'm now you know on the Tucker
Carlson broadcast like you can make that
you can make that change Tim pool can so
easily be like a right-wing grifter
while simultaneously claiming that he's
like liberal or Progressive or whatever
because ultimately uh you know a lot of
people don't care a lot of people feel
jaded they feel like uh their
politicians don't represent their
interests anyway
and that everyone's fake and uh this is
the side that does care you know people
that watch CNN people that watch even
leftovers people that watch MSNBC people
that watch Fox News like they kind of
care and when they kind of care they
only focus on the Aesthetics of the
process anyway and if you can get away
with uh you can get away with launching
a political campaign without any
established policy positions on
contentious issues which is what
politics is about
um you know you're gonna do it and
that's it it's just he's just furthering
the song and dance the facade
um the spectacle
it's sad man I really liked him you know
Brown background checks and access to
Firearms but we're not getting any of
these things Jim because the two-party
system does not need to deliver it
doesn't sound like you're taking any
hard positions
it sounds like you're you're sort of a
fill in the blank party you're you know
if somebody wants a a party with no
clear policy positions you're it but
unfortunately in the real world
in the real world you have to take a
position on something
well we're for the common sense
consensus shut the [ __ ] up bro he's like
a robot at this point we're for the
company do you believe that uh prisoners
should be executed uh for for the crime
of theft well we are a common sense
Your Leader also like I think it's just
part of your moral duty is to like part
of what you're supposed to do as a
leader is to communicate to the public
what the what the appropriate position
is on on particular issues you need to
take a stand on something even if it's
unpopular at times and and advocate for
it push for it regardless is part of the
reason why people love Bernie Sanders is
that for for almost a century this
[ __ ] has been on the right side
of issues right and has been incredibly
consistent and is very genuine and that
actually translates to uh uh you know
that that results in his incredibly High
the highest approval rating in Congress
historically yeah and consistently he's
a rare one he's a real one but honestly
just look I mean you can't really doubt
Andrew when you look at this graph it
just makes sense yeah I mean this is
just like nerd [ __ ] no no but the people
that are really interested the people
that are interested in politics and only
get their information from major media
are into nerd [ __ ] so they probably find
this to be be like unique oh how
refreshing that someone is above being a
partisan on issues
I think it is refreshing that he's
finally pushing some of the most you
know daring Against the Grain political
theories out there like the uh like the
time Cube guy
yeah
I would I would vote for this guy yeah
that's the difference
well what do you say to this uh Hassan
to the folks on the left who are upset
about the forward party what you should
be upset about is a corrupt duopoly that
manipulates you and inflames you while
serving virtually none of your actual
desired policy goals you have no policy
goals you will never get what you wanted
this and feel free to try Okay so he's
here's yet another person who is
correctly identified that the American
duopoly is unjust and is created a
system where you have yet another
fallacy of choice uh where you have a
false choice that you feel will actually
uh you know end up changing your life in
a in a positive or negative way but
ultimately there is always going to be
bipartisan consensus when it comes to
White nativist immigration policies when
it comes to deregulation when it comes
to offering the fattest checks to the
oil and gas companies even with the IRA
we saw that
um no matter what happens and and if you
truly wanted to be outside of that
spectacle if you truly had that you
would have a uh have a leftist position
that is grounded within materialism that
that Advocates to organize workers that
advocates for a mechanism of feedback uh
that that truly puts power back in the
hands of the people but you're not doing
that because if you did that then you
would be you wouldn't get the sweet CNN
jobs you wouldn't get this uh you know
MSNBC uh talking head position that
you're vying for uh you wouldn't even
maybe get the uh the the internet clout
that you're looking for when you post
off like that
um which is the reason why he's doing
this instead you're not outside of the
system you're complaining about the
system itself and yet you are still
participating in that system in the most
hilarious way because you've adopted the
Democratic party's positioning or the
Democratic parties like messaging on on
constantly trying to be a Centrist
constantly trying to be a moderate while
simultaneously not even uh you know
campaigning on issues which the
Democratic party at least a certain
degree does like there are wedge issues
those are those are the most important
things that you know differentiate a
Democrat from a republican
um and and cause this partisan divide to
continue uh running with this uh with
this fake duopoly and he's not even he's
not even doing that he's just saying
like oh we're just going to be Centrist
but like actually Centrist what does
that mean well it doesn't matter we're
just going to be in the center yeah it
just it doesn't matter oh it's so sad
rip Andrew
I remember seeing a really good tweet of
his
uh but it's hard to find this man is a
monster like Barack Obama did this he
did this he he hired like the entire
Goldman Sachs executive team you know
what I mean for the White House and and
you know look how that turned out in the
aftermath of 2008 financial uh crisis
you know in the recovery
well rest in peace Andrew it was good
while it lasted
you know we had a good run together
but onto a real yeah I was about to say
speaking of awful campaigning I was
gonna say a real up-and-comer yeah Dr Oz
oh yeah
and this guy's a shameful yes
yo Dr Oz running the worst campaign I've
ever seen in my life
it's it's pretty wild
I think like he basically thought oh
Trump is like a TV guy
and I'm a TV guy
and then because of that like you see
this man yeah I did uh I he claims to
hate socialism keeps getting publicly
owned yeah like it's such a funny it's
such a funny joke's position because you
have like on the one hand you have like
a like a TV guy who is who could not be
further removed from the actual people
whose votes he's seeking to win an
election versus a guy like John
fetterman who's like salted the Earth
but then also on top of that has been
invested
in Pennsylvania politics not only is the
lieutenant governor but as the mayor of
Braddock like this man has lived and
breathed Pennsylvania for so long uh
that you know you could not have picked
a worse person against them I think well
that doctor is destroying him in the
polls thank God I mean Dr Oz that's just
embarrassing but why are you even
running like just shut the [ __ ] go away
bro you had your show here's the thing
about Dr Oz his show first of all was
the hackiest [ __ ] ever this man is a
Charlton he's a quack he has his own
controversies section on Wikipedia
here's some of his Greatest Hits yeah
the FCC had to step in right or dude
yeah he promoted a silver solution
treatment for cold symptoms that reminds
me people were doing that during covet
and got bodied [ __ ] he pushed a
hydroxychloroquine to fight coronavirus
he really did that
yep Oz said uh astrological signs May
reveal a great deal about our health
yeah no he he is a charlatan and 100 was
like a very good doctor and he comes
from a line of like his dad is like a
very famous doctor as well that makes it
even worse because he's doing things
that are clearly against medical uh
realities for just he gets paid to
promote this [ __ ] yeah no he he reads
the room and he realizes like this is
what the wine moms are watching uh in
daytime daytime television so he's going
to feed him exactly that the irony of
course is that it's not translating to
his uh his political run Trump was very
good at reading the room right he was
very good at communicating uh despite
being like a billionaire born with a
silver spoon who was a fail son who
failed upwards his entire [ __ ] life
despite constantly Desperately Seeking
uh the the admiration of the by Coastal
elitist he claim to despise Trump did a
very good job of translating the anger
that he read on the ground and become a
vector for that whereas Dr Oz on the
other hand is doing this dumb [ __ ]
because I think he's surrounded himself
with like a horrible team like they
might be they're behaving like literally
he clearly has no sense himself at all
Republicans love winning okay he's just
so out of touch Republicans are very
good at winning so I'm actually
surprised that like they didn't put a
better team around him I think he's the
problem I think he's just that out of
touch and unlikable like he may have
gone Rogue on this one so here he is in
a this this is a recent ad he put
together that he just got absolutely
eviscerated for first of all love the
outfit what do we think about the chub
and Tuck there tucked in I'm a fan of
that I'm a fan of that that's fine I I
you know that I don't have an issue with
that
dude he's still out of place in this
grocery store this man has not shopped
for his own groceries in 20 years you
can tell well the funny thing and you'll
see what he's about to say this gives me
you remember when uh Bill Gates was on
like Ellen and she's like how much for
these pizza roll totinos and he's like I
don't know 50 bucks
yeah I mean that's just out of touch
here it is
how much could a banana cost Michael I
don't know ten dollars I can't hear him
it's on Max the volume here
uh
play I thought it was a grocery shopping
I'm at Wagner's my wife wants some
vegetables for recruiter that's not a
real grocery but okay so first of all
he's already made so many mistakes he
missed this is like a local brand in uh
Pennsylvania so I guess he's trying to
appeal to the locals but he says the
name of the grocery store wrong so
here's why he did that I'm an east coast
boy myself and I'll just Wagner's it's
called Wegmans yeah but it's not even
Wegmans because Wegmans is upscale
Wegmans is a is a decadent dining
experience you can get for the record
love Wegmans oh my God I miss those subs
every [ __ ] day however it is a more
upscale than the Redner's local uh chain
which is uh more like a Publix or a
Ralph's you know what I mean whereas
Wegmans is like maybe not as upscale as
like Whole Foods but actually probably
around the same level it was like a
Whole Foods like a upscale Pavilions if
we're gonna use like American or Los
Angeles terminology
um so he [ __ ] that up immediately the
second thing I thought that was
hilarious is that he's like I'm looking
for a crudite like what the [ __ ] are you
doing I don't I don't even know what the
[ __ ] a crudite is and it's like the dude
really thinks that was like a appeal to
the people thing my wife's like working
on a crudite board [ __ ] you mean I have
to look that up [ __ ] you made like
[ __ ] carrot sticks a veggie tray it's
just carrots it's still whack by the way
like I mean what the [ __ ] are you doing
are you eating a veggie tray nice the
people of Pennsylvania are snacking on
carrot sticks [ __ ] you
yeah I love I love trying to win over
the the vote of like uh uh like a West
Pennsylvania
uh you know looking uh driller like a
fracking guy uh by being like I'm
getting a group my wife wants me to get
a crude attack
dude uh this okay so let me just play
the whole thing it's so good it says
real salt of the earth and my wife wants
some vegetables for crudite right so
here's a broccoli that's two bucks left
a ton of broccoli there that seems like
a good deal by the way two bucks for a
head of broccoli I mean it's certainly
not bad that's the fattest head of
broccoli I've ever seen that's just
crazy is that what that looks like God
damn
but you've never seen broccoli that's a
normal size I I feel like it's big but
but I'm saying it might I mean two bucks
that seems reasonable no for a head of
Brock
it sounds about right I mean maybe maybe
a little on the I mean it's a head of
broccoli man they grew it they shipped
it I mean how cheap can you sell that
for the man's like thanks Joe Biden two
dollar broccoli yeah I don't get it yeah
but here okay I keep on pausing too much
that's two bucks not a ton of broccoli
there there's some asparagus that's four
dollars okay now I want to say about
asparagus those are those they've always
been expensive also those are big ones
dude yeah
American [ __ ] vegetables are so crazy
dude they all fat chutiness of them
everything is just like have you ever
seen the the chickens like chickens have
grown four times
yeah they're like 4X larger that's like
literally that's four times like your
dream physique bro well I do like it
with the chicken because like hopefully
some of that steroids also like you know
feeds my mom yeah but like I just I hate
it with the vegetables well I'll be
honest I skipped the chubby asparagus I
like it thin because yeah it Cooks
through it gets better but I've been
buying asparagus for decades and I'll
tell you even like 10 15 years ago when
I was grocery shopping for myself
asparagus is expensive it ranges between
three and five dollars for a for a grabs
also I don't is is it a spare you can't
put asparagus on a veggie tray what are
you gonna hit that raw that's crazy that
is obviously you're gonna dump it into
you're gonna dump it in the ranch and
eat it raw this that's why you're not
cruditang raw asparagus you [ __ ] oh
people are saying four dollars is cheap
yeah I mean that's what I think too
I don't think that's very expensive
carrots
that's four more dollars that's ten
dollars bro that's like a lifetime
supply of carrots yeah I'm just I'm not
gonna complain about that being four
bucks no he's [ __ ] uh serving
food The Bugs Bunny right
he's got the most amount of carrots in
there I mean it's fake anyway it's not
real like he's not no but the point is
that the ad is so [ __ ] bad yeah I
couldn't even find expensive prices to
thank Joe Biden for yeah people are
saying that's cheap as hell especially
there and then I looked it up average
price in the US for a pound of broccoli
is a dollar fifty to five dollars
depending on the area now that didn't
look like a pound necessarily a little
under but yeah still it seems like it's
in the range right there it's right
there yeah
we need some guacamole that's four
dollars or more
yeah buying pre-made guacamole is always
expensive and by the way avocados are
expensive yeah avocados are very always
been expensive yeah this man has never
bought groceries for himself that's what
it's that's what I'm getting yeah
she loves salsa yeah salsa there six
dollars yeah it takes labor to create
that [ __ ] six dollars six dollars I've
never seen that much money in my life
yeah
um
but no no the best part is here continue
this doesn't include a tequila
dude you are so [ __ ] loser he's so
[ __ ] bad at it oh my God it's pretty
he's like oh I gotta get tequila for my
wife you know Dr Oz is super rich why
don't you just [ __ ] retire and enjoy
your life and spend time with you like I
usually don't understand the desires
because this is like a way to just have
some more forward momentum on your brand
people are like using Politics as a but
he really wants to win he's not this no
no dude he's he I think he had a shot of
at one point you know well yeah but
again I mean under the nomination
fetterman is legitimately uh a man of
the people you know what I mean as close
as that I disagree that I disagree with
you that he I think he wants to win yeah
I mean if he wins and it's great he will
be able to uh you know do he will be
able to get this like uh you know very
pretty powerful position as a senator
and uh maybe even get some lobbying uh
dollars on the side you know this bad
it's according to Google is worth
upwards of half a billion dollars he
said I think it's you don't need
lobbying I think uh I think it's more so
the the flex like I was able to do this
I'm I'm so successful I was able to you
know achieve success here as well yo
he's so [ __ ] bad I just love this oh
we should Sound by this Zack I mean it's
outrageous we got Joe Biden a thing for
this bro that's 20 bucks like first of
all you [ __ ] probably spent 20 bucks
on like you I'm like an artisan grape so
an actual veggie tray if you're gonna
get that which is weak sauce by the way
[ __ ] that [ __ ] um
if you want to actually get a
vegetariance like six bucks I think like
so you don't need to do any of that but
of course you know
um he was just trying to make a video
out of this
um he had a lot of he had a lot of weird
things though that's not it doesn't it
doesn't end there
um the grocery store is also called
Redner's not wegeners and it's not even
that he's inside of it's a disaster and
we love that no let's see what he let's
see how he defended himself though yes
so then he goes uh so he this goes viral
and he has to defend himself here we go
Dr Oz dismisses
the Wagner's criticism I've got my kids
names wrong
hey come on
I don't even remember my own kids names
well you're shooting a political ad
reshoot it dumbass
I love that you weren't live streaming
it does he say it in this yeah yeah he's
like he's like I'm actually a way bigger
dumbass than you previously I don't
remember Alton so you're [ __ ] owned
I'm yeah elect me I don't remember
nothing about nobody
hear what he had to say
you did
Newsmax by the way great great uh
appearance there I just for those
watching in Pennsylvania you know how
particular many people are about their
groceries what happened with Wegmans and
can you explain that to them
yeah I was exhausted but you're
campaigning 18 hours a day you've
listened I've gotten my kids names wrong
as well I don't think that's a measure
of someone's what's your name Ryan Brian
yeah whether I name you again Joseph no
this is great this is this is a
wonderful way to continue campaigning I
think he's just you should you should
keep it up I mean this is like the The
only positive of this is that like it
kind of Tanks Doug mastriano too a
little bit because like a lot of people
go out they vote if they like one
particular candidate and they vote down
ballot right now Governor races are a
little bit different people do actually
look at the individual Governors that's
why you have like red states with blue
Governors and blue states with red
Governors Dogma show is like a [ __ ]
psychopath that's the governor that's
the guy who's running he's like a like a
q Anon like yeah you know uh you know
we're gonna the he's like straight up q
a moral crazy more or less crazy than
the lady running for Arizona governor no
no more more he's like I think he is
like a genuine like you can kind of tell
from the the look in their eyes like
whether someone is like a genuine crazy
versus someone like Carrie Lake who's
like a media machine person you know
what I mean the dog is he's he's the
real deal
so you think Oz is doing so [ __ ] bad
he's actually tanking
that guy's chances to win it could
happen
he's also currently way behind thank God
now we're we're too far out I don't want
to say anything it's just even even
that's too close for someone that crazy
you know yeah no the fact that he has a
40 is is wild to me because he's like
straight like I think he has like real
groupers in his [ __ ] uh in his team
as well like he has like
yeah he hired like the guy who created
gab like actual white supremacist wow
okay I love him yeah right right yeah it
was the Gap guy yeah he is he is not
like he's not hiding and he's like based
and red pilled on on the main yeah so Dr
Oz's horrible campaign continues on
Twitter he's making hit videos on his
opponent uh fetterman who has become
beloved really on the left the guys
[ __ ] awesome based he wears gym
shorts and big ass hoodies everywhere
yeah have we shown his fits Dan I don't
remember I think at one point but it's
worth his fits are insane dude you guys
this is a man of the people yeah
six eight he's gigantic is he that tall
yeah he's huge he's oh yeah here the
tower is over me look oh my he's a
monster he's a big boy and and guess
what America office Americans love big
boys okay
but but not like tall boys like you
can't be [ __ ] skinny like that that's
the that's the beauty of John fetterman
is that like first of all shorts and a
hoodie is a wild it's snowy there's snow
on the back that's my man right there of
course yeah Ethan supports that fully
because Ethan is good exclusively wears
shorts so so he is he is uh he is a
really interesting character
uh big Bernie supporter big Bernie
Advocate Big Bird the jump uh I guess
like
he has some he has some takes like his
foreign policy uh slam he did not want
to get like attacked by Democratic
majority for Israel so immediately he
was like I love Israel Pennsylvania
loves Israel Israel can do whatever it
wants nice resolution on that one guys
yeah uh and then real quick on top of
that I think like he's he's of course
he's like pro-fracking he is okay West
Pennsylvania yeah yeah West Pennsylvania
he's like listen this is like very
important for us like you have to be at
least to some degree like he's still
he's the representative he's a
representative but he's still back in
like green New Deal he's like he's like
a very interesting person that way um
so anyway the the fat the wet the fetty
waps I was looking for more fit checks
but the honest truth is he wears like
two outfits like I've shown you both
I've shown you his entire wardrobe at
this point all of the pictures yeah he
wears a lot of Carhartt and just like
the longest shorts show up
into the Senate and [ __ ] Jim shorts
my dudes and that is everything to me
yeah no he's he's great he's by anyway
here's the hit piece that Dr Oz tries to
pass on him he says he's the most
radical candidate in the country
now that John fetterman claims to be
recovering let's pull back his hoodie
and examine what's in his head looks
like he has some screws loose what's
this oh the first thing we find is screw
no they're they're going after the
JibJab audience
they're they're gonna nail that
constituency down and then you'll who
will be laughing then huh this is like
just as far as political hit videos go
this is just so bad
it's like not even hard hitting it's
like oh welcome to the circus we're
having a good time no it truly
undermines the severity like they are
trying to make a make a hit piece and be
like John fetterman wants to release one
third of the prisoner population of
Pennsylvania which like
just be racist like why what are you
doing like I I not to give you pointers
but like why aren't you doing this in
the most racist way possible you're
you're right you know if it ain't broke
don't fix it that's how that's how
Republicans run but instead they're like
whoo look at this oh it's a carnival
yeah like No One's Gonna take this
seriously no let's have fun yeah
it's looks like he has some screws loose
what's this
yeah
also like the the accusation he smokes
weed I mean nobody gives a [ __ ] anymore
this isn't 1950. yeah no it's actually
it's like shut it's like it's like a
broadly no he's literally posting his
own elves by showing John federman's
dubs because
the The Prisoner won they could probably
nail them on pretty hard
um because you know
the the crime narrative is like pretty
uh it has a lot of staying power uh
right now there's been so much like agit
prop revolving around crime and in local
news that's one thing that he could like
probably hit him on more frequently
um don't know what fetterman's position
is on that I don't know why he's saying
that that that's what he wants to do
um but let's continue there's there's
more good stuff you said you just say
it's racist that they don't want
prisoners out what do you mean by that
no no no no I'm saying just be racist oh
instead and be like John fetterman wants
like a black person that uh you know
killed someone to come into your
neighborhood and like kill you yeah but
it's by releasing all the people coming
out of his head
they're like sjw looking yeah I don't
know I mean they they didn't even do
that that's what I'm saying because like
because this is a tried and true tactic
for the Republican party let's watch
let's watch
this better man wants to release one
third of all prisoners that's awesome
that's crazy that's crazy these prices
are out of control yeah come on down to
Dr Oz's used car lot
also if I was a doctor who has been
caught by the federal government for
doing snake oil sales like I would try
to move away from that as best as
possible and you just nailed it like he
this is like yeah Dr Oz is snake oil
Emporium this is odd because Dr Oz
previously said in 2017 medical
marijuana could help solve opioid
addiction well yeah because he was a lib
and he still is kind of he's just like
faking it what happened bro
he's faking which that [ __ ] up real yeah
let's see let's see what else is
that's easy they're crazy spend more tax
dollars everything will cost more
nuts yeah no slow energy production gas
prices will Skyrocket that's ridiculous
socialize this part's great
free health care for everyone bro what
the [ __ ] that's not even you didn't even
add a negative slant to that oh that
literally just said something good he's
just he's campaigning for he wants you
to be healthy John fetterman wants you
not to die because you have diabetes you
guys are supposed to slant it in some
way where it's like worse yeah no they
just free medicine is worse medicine
something like that yeah no he's just
like but look ioc's promoting it so it
must be bad this is like honestly it's
so close to a pro
yeah a Pro ad for him that is kind of
hard yeah it's kind of hard to
[Music]
blah blah better close it up yeah no
definitely definitely also keep
associating John fetterman with Bernie
Sanders like who is insanely popular
again yeah definitely keep associating
John Federman with Bernie Sanders in
Pennsylvania I'm sure I'm sure people
will hate that
they will say oh no
like they didn't work you know what's
really you know what's really [ __ ]
stupid okay
I always say this but Republicans they
they don't like losers they like winners
okay Democrats love losers they will hug
and kiss the losers they will say hey as
long as you lost with Grace then that's
fine you will always have a job in the
Democratic party this ad unironically
feels like uh like a like a liberal
like this would be the this is the
closest I've ever seen to a republican
candidate running like a liberal
campaign like liberals always do this
[ __ ] where they have like these failing
strategies that they continue harping on
like putting a [ __ ] military veteran
in a in an ad and being like look I
lasered a bunch of 14 year old kids in
Pakistan like please vote for me over
this other guy who's not patriotic like
I am and then it's like you're running
for South Dakota it's not gonna [ __ ]
happen they don't give a [ __ ] right
and and they do it regularly
and they keep failing right they keep
failing over and over again this is the
closest I've ever seen a republican run
like a liberal style campaign where his
own team of Consultants are just owning
him like they're owning Dr Oz yeah
um I think it's the worst political ad
I've ever seen in my life yeah they
didn't even [ __ ] put Nancy Pelosi or
Chuck Schumer anyway right that's insane
Nancy blows is one of the least popular
politicians in the [ __ ] country are
you [ __ ] stupid like go back to the
basics idiot you don't have to like try
to associate him with Bernie Sanders you
dumb idiot that's not gonna work yeah
but his his L his L's continue this just
came out they asked so Dr Oz turns out
he owns 10 [ __ ] houses
he's worth half a billion Wegmans
[ __ ] going
people the uh man of the people owns ten
houses so somebody asked him yo uh
doctor us how many houses do you own
[Music]
oh gotcha that's very cool thank you
very much you're welcome once again yeah
so he lied he owns ten houses
so he owns 10 houses of course he does
he's Rich As [ __ ] he you could tell he's
like oh I don't like this question yeah
um well especially because like they
were trying to do a hit piece on him
which was like really stupid too they
like he I think he has like houses in
New Jersey that like he gave to a family
friends that are just like living there
for free yeah and then anyway that's
besides the point but
um
he
he uh he does that and then last night
he actually tweeted something about that
where John fetterman I believe made fun
of him if you pull up my I tweeted about
it as well here pull up
no no go to go to my profile like it's
like one of the last tweets they had the
back and forth him and Oz yeah yeah I
got it here yeah
yeah
so
uh yeah oh here it is here it is here it
is here it is so I've never spoken to a
Pennsylvania resident who doesn't know
how many houses they have let alone be
off by eight now obviously like this
Twitter spat back and forth is no matter
how well it looks for John fetterman I
think we should not make the mistake
that like Twitter likes are going to
equal uh actual likes on the ground what
he's doing is great with the campaigning
door-to-door and like being a man of the
people and you should continue doing
that shouts out to his social team I got
a lot of friends uh like a lot of
mutuals working with this campaign
um some of the some good uh Bernie Bros
in there and you know they're doing a
great job owning them on Twitter but
like this stuff is ultimately
meaningless I think I think it all is
good you know yeah I mean but it's fun
it's fun for us to look at but like
definitely the solid fundamentals need
to be focused on but this conversation
was really interesting because he says
I've never spoken up John Federer says
I've never spoken to a Pennsylvania
resident who doesn't know how many
houses they have let alone be off by
eight I can't tell if he's trying plus
failing to sound like a regular person
with only two Mansions or if he
genuinely has no idea
and then he quote tweets it and says I
purchased houses my houses with my money
you lived off your parents until you
were almost 50. regular people don't
mooch off their parents when they're 50.
get off the couch John and and what I
find really particularly interesting
about that [ __ ] line of attack is
that you are straight up like [ __ ]
on your constituents yeah right people
are not doing well then yeah
exactly multi-generational uh uh
households
it's not exactly super commonplace in
America it's not a part of American
culture but it is now becoming a part of
American culture it's certainly a part
of Dr Oz's culture for the record by the
way he's Turkish so that's even
additionally weird that he said that
really [ __ ] shameful
um you're supposed to take care of your
parents and you're supposed to live with
your parents too like it's a totally
normal thing but making fun of that in
America especially in Pennsylvania just
screams I don't know my [ __ ] favorite
audiences because the reason why
multi-generational uh houses are growing
in America is because of the housing
crisis that we are currently facing this
is the kind of conversation you would
have at the uh country club with your
millionaire friends yeah
they don't know how to work hard and buy
[ __ ] 10 houses so so John said how
many houses and he said I have 10
properties [ __ ] owned two homes my
turn when can we debate that's great I
mean they should debate I think I think
John Fender will [ __ ] destroy him but
um you know I don't know I I don't know
why they haven't done it there was that
but then so let's see here John
fetterman tweeted this out let's see
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh my God those are nice houses oh [ __ ]
yo
yo this is actually shocking because
those are all like insane pads yeah
okay I see oh
dude that was insane that house is
that's his real house the New Jersey
Mansion one that's where he actually
lives yeah this man he doesn't live in
Pennsylvania like he actually lives
there but he like uh acts like he lives
with his mother-in-law like his in-laws
because they live in Pennsylvania wait
he lives with this what happened I
thought he was against that no I I think
he like bought it basically okay dude
look at the size of this house this
guy's shopping for crudite for his wife
yeah he's outraged by the twenty dollars
he has to spend on crew today
ingredients meanwhile [ __ ] John
Federman living in Braddock like lives
in a in a repurposed like Auto Gallery
or something
this is probably the only one with high
enough roofs for this [ __ ] he
has a house in Ireland that has like
insanely baller too yeah
so a New York City condo that ain't
cheap
I don't know what the [ __ ] this is big
old plot of land in Florida another New
York condo [ __ ] that that is such an on
though
yeah so you know he's owning him on on
you know Twitter Twitter likes are not
that important for overall campaigning
though because if that was the case then
Bernie Sanders would be president you
know what I mean he's owning people all
the time it's not everything but I do
think it helps
certainly I've got enough on its own you
know what I mean yeah I mean the real
reason why he's failing is because he's
just [ __ ] failing like he's really
bad he's really bad at campaigning and
that's why you see the disparity between
fetterman and Oz versus uh mastriano and
uh
who's the I don't know the the person
running for uh Pennsylvania governor
let's [ __ ] go Dr Oz at when is the
election by the way
November oh it's in November November
8th so is it up there on the right
I'm looking forward to that that'll be
interesting yeah I am kind of it's nice
that the Dems are looking good in the
Senate but the house is like a nightmare
like Marciano and Shapiro are going uh
with a like Shapiro is leading uh
gaining more momentum macciano's at 40
Dr Oz on the other hand is at 37 so uh
that's that that disparity is coming
from the fact that Dr Oz is like
genuinely I think uh campaigning
horribly well I know you gotta go do you
want to wrap it up here yeah yeah
thank you everybody it's been a fun
episode a great episode uh Amy how are
you feeling you're recovering it's one
of my favorites let me see I did I get a
message from uh papa no no further
updates from big papa no further updates
yeah but we got what was important it's
gone dark Papa's gone dark yes so um the
Day of Reckoning is upon us yes so
anyway Hassan thank you so much great to
see you
uh peanuts teddyfresh.com
foreign
all right bye everybody
see you guys next time see you tomorrow
for after dark and anyway well that was
[Music]